GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
GENEROUS OR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE QUORUM BUT
WE WILL START.
OUR AS A SUBCOMMITTEE I'M GONNA
ASK MEMBERS OF OUR HOUSING
COMMITTEE TO PLEASE JOIN US SO --
WITH THAT WE HAVE OUR FIRST
AUTHOR FILE AND ONE SB FIVE IF I
COULD ASK THE AUDIENCE TO PLEASE
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS.
OUTSIDE AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE
JUST GOT QUORUM SO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
TWO HERE TO HEAR DAVE HERE.
THE PAIR GABRIELLE GABRIELLE
HERE GLORIA.
KILEY.
LEE MON.
THE MAN HERE MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA.
OVER HERE AND WITH THAT WE HAVE
COR AND WITH THAT SENATOR BILL --
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SB.
FIVE SB FIVE AS PART OF A
PACKAGE OF BILLS SO.
THAT MISTER -- CENTER MCGUIRE.
AND I INTRODUCED THIS YEAR WE
ARE JUST AS BEFORE FIVE AND SIX
THIS PACKAGE IS BASED ON INPUT
ABOUT GATHERED THROUGH A SERIES
OF PUBLIC HEARINGS -- WE CONVENE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- LAST
FALL.
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING -- CRISIS
IS STAGGERING.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
CALIFORNIA HAS FAILED TO PRODUCE
THE HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
NECESSARY NEW HOUSING UNITS PER
YEAR.
AS A RESULT NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND MEN WOMEN
AND CHILDREN LIVED IN OUR
STREETS LAST YEAR.
THIS IS OFTEN A MISCONCEPTION
ABOUT.
WHO WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WHEN WE
SAY HOMELESS?
COLLEGE STUDENTS WORKING
FAMILIES OUR NEIGHBORS ARE BEING
PUSHED INTOHOMELESS THOSE.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD THE
RISING RENTS.
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
HISTORIC ONE TIME INVESTMENTS TO
HELP SHELTER THOSE ON OUR CITY
STREETS.
AND PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT FUNDS TO
GET LOCAL GOVERNMENT INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENTS BUT REALLY FAILS TO
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSE OF ARE
HOMELESS.
NOW THIS PROBLEM WHICH IS THE
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS
THERE ARE TWO POINT TWO MILLION.
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME AND VERY
LOW INCOME RENTER HOUSEHOLDS.
COMPETING FOR ONLY SIX HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOMES.
THIS LEAVES MORE THAN ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS OF THE
LOWEST INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT
ACCESS TO HOUSING AND AT RISK OF
BECOMING HOMELESS.
CITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES.
DESPITE THE BEST INTENTIONS ARE
STRUGGLING TO KEEP UP WITH THE
EVER GROWING PRODUCTION NEEDS TO
KEEP BRENT BURDEN AND VERY LOW
INCOME FAMILIES OFF OUR STREETS.
MARKET RATE HOUSING IS PART OF
THE SOLUTION BUT WITHOUT
DELIBERATE INVESTMENTS IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT
CONTRIBUTES TO A RISING COST OF
RENTS THAT'S WHY THE STATE NEEDS
TO INVEST IN ALL ITS ONGOING
FUNDS TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SB FIVE MAKES THE STATE A LONG
TERM FINANCIAL PARTNER. TO
IMMEDIATELY CONSTRUCT NEEDED
HOUSING FOR HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS AND COMPLIMENTS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AND OUR RECENT -- TWENTY
NINETEEN INVESTMENT.
THE BILL CREATES A EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND NEW AND REHABILITATED
HOUSING UNITS.
HELPS REAL.
BILL OF LEVY A POVERTY CREATE
JOBS.
AND MEETS OUR STATE WHERE TO
BERMAN GOALS WITHOUT AFFECTING
SCHOOL FUNDING.
SPECIFICALLY SB FIVE ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO COLLABORATE
ON ON STATE APPROVED COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT PLANS.
WHICH WOULD BE FUNDED BY
REDUCING THE CONTRIBUTION FOR
THE EDUCATIONAL REVENUE
AUGMENTATION FUND FOR EMPHASIS
WILL BE PAGE TO THE DEVELOPMENT
OF HOUSING FOR VERY LOW.
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES
AS WELL AS TRANSIT OR IN
PRIORITY PROJECTS.
ADDITIONALLY INFILL DEVELOPMENTS
IN PROJECTS THAT MITIGATE.
THE THE FACTS OF SEA LEVEL RISE
IN CLIMATE CHANGE ARE ALSO
PRIORITIZE.
THE BILL WILL CREATE A CAP ON
AVAILABLE FUNDING A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION ANNUALLY AFTER.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AFTER THE
PROGRAM IS WRAPPED UP THE TOTAL
ANNUAL GENERAL FUND SPENDING
COULD EXCEED -- TWO HUNDRED TWO
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THE STATE GENERAL FUNDS WILL BE
USED TO BACK FILL SCHOOLS.
LEGISLATURE CONSISTS BAND NEW
PLANS DURING FISCAL DOWNTURNS.
THE BILL ALIGNS WITH OTHER STATE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS TO ENSURE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LEVERAGE ADDITIONAL
NON STATE.
GENERAL FUNDS THE LEGISLATION
CREATES A STRONG ACCOUNTABILITY
PROVISIONS TO ENSURE FUNDS ARE
ONLY SPENT ON DESIGNATED
PROJECTS AND TO PROTECT SCHOOL
FUNDING.
THE BILL CREATES A STATE
COMMITTEE HOUSING.
HOUSE AND H. C. D.. TO REVIEW
AND APPROVE PROPOSED PLANS
PROVIDING STRONG STATE OVERSIGHT.
COMMITTEES ALSO IN POWER TO TAKE
CORRECTION CORRECTIVE ACTION
WHEN LOCALS DO NOT MEET THEIR
PLANS OBJECTIVES.
IT'S OF THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD COALITION OF BUSINESS
LABOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HOUSING
ADVOCATES -- MISSED TERMINAL
TURNED MY WITNESSES -- WE HAVE
SAYS OUR DS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADE.
AND CHASE AND RYAN AS
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR RIDLEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
TARA MY WITH THIS MISTER JOHN
YOUR WITNESSES.
MISTER MEMBER SISTER DIEM HALF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
PROUD US SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
WHICH WE BELIEVE IS A CREATIVE
POLICY. TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND ASSIST THEM WITH
THE DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING INFILL DEVELOPMENT.
AND PLANNING FOR THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
ALL THIS IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHILE ENSURING GOOD
JOBS TO THE USE OF PREVAILING
WAGE IN A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORK FORCE THAT ADDRESSES THE
PERCEIVED TO WORK FOR SHORTAGE
IN THE RESIDENTIAL MARKET.
IT'S NOT EVERY DAY THAT YOU SEE
A BILL THAT HAS ALL OF THESE --
ATTRIBUTES -- INCLUDED IN IT.
IT'S A VERY CREATIVE SOLUTION
IT'S A A WIDE RANGE OF COALITION
AND STAKEHOLDERS OUT --
DEVELOPED THIS POLICY.
WE BELIEVE THAT.
WELL IMPORTANT FUNDING HAS BEEN
ACHIEVED THROUGH SB TO AN SB
THREE OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
FACT IS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NEED
ONGOING FINANCING TOOLS TO HELP
FUND PROJECTS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
IN THE BROADER INFRASTRUCTURE
NECESSARY TO INCREASE HOUSING
PRODUCTION.
SB FIVE ALSO SEEKS TO FILL THE
GAP LEFT BY THE DISSOLUTION OF
PARTY ETS THE REDEVELOPMENT --
SAYS -- AGENCIES.
AND PROVIDES HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FUNDING
THAT WILL HELP WORKING FAMILIES.
WITH THE CONTINUES THE RISING
COST OF HOUSING AND THE EVER
GROWING PROBLEM OF INCOME
INEQUALITY IN THE STATE.
THE PREVAILING WAGE UNSKILLED
UNTRAINED ARE PROVISIONS ARE
IMPORTANT LABOR PROTECTIONS THAT
ARE ONLY LEAD TO GOOD
CONSTRUCTION BUT ALSO ENSURE
THAT THIS CRITICALLY NEEDED.
THESE GRILL YOU NEED A PROJECTS
ARE BUILT WITH THE HIGHEST GUILD
LABOR -- THAT IS AVAILABLE AND
ALSO ADDRESSES THE WORK FOR
SHORTAGE BY ENSURING THAT
THERE'S APPRENTICES ACTUALLY ON
THOSE JOBS SO THAT ALSO ALLOWS A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE EXITING
THE HIGH SCHOOLS IN GOING
THROUGH.
A PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM TO
ENTER THE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
THAT STATE APPROVED SYSTEM.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS COMPLEMENTARY
TO THE GOVERNOR'S HOUSING GOALS
AND PROVIDE NEW OPPORTUNITIES
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO WORK TOGETHER
TO REVITALIZE COMMUNITIES AND
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
THESE REASONS WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND WE'VE
TOUCHED ON A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT'S IN
THE THE BUDGET THIS YEAR AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. TO TO
REALLY FOCUS IN ON ON AN ITEM
THAT YOU KNOW YOU CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT OVER THE YEARS IN A FOUGHT
EVERY YEAR FOR AND THAT'S THE
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM.
ON THE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THERE WHICH I THINK IS IS QUITE
SIGNIFICANT I'M WHILE IT IS ONE
TIME FUNDING YOU KNOW IT WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THAT EFFORT
AND GRADUALLY YOU IN YOUR
EFFORTS. TO TO GET THAT INCLUDED
SB FIVE REALLY BUILDS OFF THAT
IN SB FIVE WOULD WOULD BE A LONG
TERM PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT YOU KNOW
CITY SOMETIMES ARE BLAMED FOR
PUTTING A BEARS AND AND NOT
WANTING TO TO NECESSARILY BE
PARTNERS WHEN IT COMES TO
BUILDING.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HOUSING IN
GENERAL AND I THINK FROM THIS
BILL YOU CAN SEE THAT WE HAVE
DOZENS AND DOZENS OF CITIES WHO
ARE LINING UP AND SAYING PLEASE
PARTNER WITH US WERE WILLING TO
PUT UP OUR OWN DOLLARS.
IF THE STATE'S WILLING TO PUT UP
SOME OF THEIR DOLLARS AND WE CAN
TEAM UP AND ACTUALLY YOU KNOW
ACHIEVE COMMON GOALS AND THOSE
COMMON GOALS.
ARE REALLY OUTLINED IN THE BILL
BUT THEY'RE ALSO OUTLINED IN IN
PREVIOUS BILLS YOU KNOW IT'S ALL
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURES ABOUT
INFILL IT'S ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE
NEAR TRANSIT IT'S ARE DOING MORE
DENSITY.
LORRAINE GHGS THESE ARE ALL
COMMON GOALS THAT WE A CITY
SHARE WITH THE STATE -- AND
THAT'S WHY WE ARE SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE NOT ONLY DOES
IT TO SUPPORT THOSE WITHTHE
DOLLARS BUT ALSO WILL ACHIEVE
THOSE GOALS -- I ALSO THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
THIS BILL BUILDS OFF OF THE
REALLY HARD WORK THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE'S DONE.
OVER THE PAST FIVE OR SEVEN
YEARS WHEN YOU GUYS BROUGHT BACK --
YOU KNOW III OF TEASING CREE IS
AND YOU GAVE US THESE POWERFUL
TOOLS -- TO GET UNITS
CONSTRUCTED THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT
WAS ONE REALLY KEY INGREDIENT
THAT WAS MISSING AND I WAS
FUNDING AND THIS BILL DOES THAT
SO IT'S ACTUALLY YOU KNOW BY
PASSING THIS BILL AND ALLOCATING
THE FUNDS -- YOU'LL ALSO BE ABLE
TO YOU KNOW TO FUND THE ACT OF
THE VERY -- PROGRAMS YOU GUYS
CONSTRUCTED I AND WE CAN GET OUT
THERE AND START GETTING UNITS --
BUILT IN OUR COMMUNITIES. ONE
FINAL THING I I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW THOUGH IS THAT -- THIS BILL
NOT ONLY IS A SORT OF A CITIES
BUT IS SUPPORTED BY YOU KNOW
BROAD COALITION AND I THINK THAT
REALLY LENDS TO THE TO THE
MERITS OF THE MEASURE AND WE
CERTAINLY WOULD STRONGLY
APPRECIATE.
TO A SUPPORT POSITION ON THIS
BILL AND MOVE BEFORE
[inaudible]
OTHER SUPPORTERS.
RICHARD MEMBERS SYLVIA SILLY
SHAUN BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS AND SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DOMINIC
TOMORROW HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF NAPA WEST SACRAMENTO
HAND RIVERSIDE IN SUPPORT.
WHICH YOUR TOYS WITH CHARLIE AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS PROSPECTING ABOUT
THE SECOND AMERICA DEL STEINBERG
AND SUPPORT.
SELENA PRIOR CALIFORNIA STATE
AND DOUBLE ACP IN SUPPORT.
MR SURE MEMBERS CAN BE DONE HIT
AROUND WITH THE STATE COUNCIL
LABORS AND SUPPORT.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS MIKE MON
AGAIN WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARTRIDGE COUNCIL WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL **** WORKERS.
AND THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION ALL IN
SUPPORT.
MARY ELLEN SHEA CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES IN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY STRONG SUPPORT.
SCOTT GOVERNOR HAVE THE
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
I'M NOT ABOUT OTHER ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE IN SUPPORT.
MATT CRIMMINS ON WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ERIN GILBERT FOR THE CITY OF
ANTHONY JUST IN SUPPORT.
A JAMES SWEENEY -- WITH BAY
PACKED A BLACK AMERICAN
POLITICAL ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF
UNITED CONTRACTORS IN SUPPORT.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT WHEN I THINK
THE AUTHOR FURS DILIGENT WORK
WITH US TO ENSURE THERE ARE
UNINTENDED.
I'M CONSEQUENCES FOR PROPERTY
TAXES TO COUNTIES.
MORNING CAMINO BEHALF OF MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT.
MY QUEST ON BEHALF OF DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES IN SUPPORT.
CHRISTOPHER MIGHT NOT BE HAVE A
HOUSING CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING KERR PLAQUE ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS AND
AGAIN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
**** GEORGE OF THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CARE US ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF BURBANK
GLENDALE PASADENA SOUTH PASADENA
STOCKTON AND THE MARIN COUNTY
COUNCIL MAYORS AND COUNCIL
MEMBERS ALL IN SUPPORT.
ALEX GIVES HERE WE HAVE THE
FOLLOWING CITIES PISMO BEACH
DANVILLE DUBLIN LIVERMORE
PLEASANTON SAN RAMON AT LAGUNA
BEACH STANTON PLACENTIA
CUPERTINO AND LAFAYETTE IN
SUPPORT.
MORNING MR JERMICHAEL IN SKI
CITY OF ROSEVILLE AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE MORNING HERE IN THE CITY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THANK.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BOB NAYLOR I
REPRESENT FEELS SUDDEN COMPANY
WHICH IS HOWARD ALMONDS IN
JUNIOR.
IS -- AS A RESIDENT ORANGE
COUNTY AS AN LONG CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ADVERSE IMPACT OF
REDEVELOPMENT [inaudible]
ON MINORITY AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
AND SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EFFORT THE GOVERNOR BROWN'S
EFFORT -- TO DISSOLVE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES.
WE REALLY RESPECT SENATOR BELL
AND HIS TIRELESS EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS BUT
WE THINK MOVING TO A
REDEVELOPMENT MODEL AS AS
PROBLEMATIC FOR SEVERAL REASONS.
ONE IS -- EMINENT DOMAIN ABUSE
THAT IS THE TAKING OF PRIVATE
PROPERTY FROM UNWILLING SELLERS.
SOMETIMES LEAVING IT VACANT FOR
MANY MANY YEARS OFTEN IN
MINORITY COMMUNITIES AND
EVENTUALLY TURNING IT OVER OVER
TO OTHER.
PRIVATE DEVELOPERS.
AT AND TO ACCOMMODATE A LOCAL
PLAN.
THE RECORD ONTHAT HAS BEEN VERY
SKETCHY NOW I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
SOME DISPUTE ABOUT WHETHER
EMINENT DOMAIN AS PART OF THIS
BILL BUT AND ON PAGE TWENTY FOUR
LINE.
TWENTY TWO THE NEW AGENCIES
CREATED UNDER THIS BILL OR GET
ARM POWER TO DO ANY OTHER ACT
THAT IS NECESSARY.
AND OUR LEGAL COUNSEL -- AND WE
CONSULTED AS WELL THE PACIFIC
LEGAL FOUNDATION AGREE THAT THAT
ENCOMPASSES ANY OTHER ACT
INCLUDING EMINENT DOMAIN.
AND ALSO THIS MONEY CAN GO TO
SEE OUR I. A.'S ONE OF THE LOCAL
REDEVELOPMENT.
ITEMS THAT THAT WAS ENACTED IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND THAT IS
EXPLICITLY GRANTED EMINENT
DOMAIN POWER -- SECONDLY -- WE
THINK THIS BILL HAS SERIOUS
FISCAL PROBLEMS.
IN THAT IT COULD CREATE A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR A YEAR --
OBLIGATION OVER THIRTY YEARS TO
PAY OFF THE BONDS THAT ARE
ISSUED BY LOCAL AGENCIES AGAINST
THE FUNDING STREAM.
THAT MEANS THAT IN TIMES OF
RECESSION -- YOU'VE GOT.
NO FLEXIBILITY YOU CAN'T CUT
THAT PROGRAM -- YOU HAVE TO KEEP
PAYING OFF THOSE BONDS WERE
STILL PAYING OFF BONDS FROM THE
FORMER REDEVELOPMENT AT TO THE
TUNE OF TWO BILLION DOLLARS
YOU'RE FROM THE GENERAL FUND SO.
ALL OTHER PROGRAMS IN RECESSION
OR SO INCLUDING.
EDUCATION ARE SUBJECT.
TO BEING REDUCE [inaudible]
THIRDLY.
ONLY 50% OF THE MONEY IN THESE
THE IN THIS BILL.
HAS TO GO TO HOUSING.
WE THINK IT IS SUPERIOR TO HAVE
A GRANT PROGRAM.
ANNUALLY.
APPROPRIATED AS PART OF THE
BUDGET.
THAT IS PAYS YOU GO AND IS
TARGETED 1100% TO HOUSING.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
JOURNAL VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THEY'RE BACK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION -- WE
HAVE A AND OPPOSE UNLESS AMEND A
POSITION I JUST BEFORE I BEGIN
JUST WANNA THANK THE SENATOR FOR
WORKING WITH US -- OUR COALITION --
IS OFFICE AND THE STAFF HAVE
BEEN TREMENDOUS AND LISTEN TO
OUR CONCERNS -- WE JUST SIMPLY
HAVE A PHILOSOPHICAL DEBATE
ABOUT THE USE OF THE RAF FUNDING.
EDUCATION FUNDING TO PAY FOR
HOUSING.
OUR POSITION IS THAT WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S ALTERNATIVE SOURCES
OF FUNDING TO PAY.
FOR HOUSING ISSUES IF IT'S A
PRIORITY OF THE LEGISLATURE AS
MY A PREVIOUS.
SPEAKER IT MENTIONED THERE THAT
THE THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
DEDICATE FUNDING FOR THAT
PURPOSE WE ALSO POINT TO
PROPOSITION ONE FROM LAST YEAR
THAT SET ASIDE FOR BILLION
DOLLARS.
IN STATE APPROVED BONDS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AS WE FEEL LIKE THERE'S ALREADY
A MECHANISM BY WHICH TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE THAT DOESN'T HAVE.
TO IMPACT THE STABILITY OF
EDUCATION FUNDING OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE UNCERTAINTY OUT WHEN
ECONOMIC TIMES BECOME
CHALLENGING WHAT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE DO IN THE FUTURE
YEARS.
WHAT WILL THIS LEGISLATURE JAIL
IF THERE'S A FISCAL CRISIS AND
HOW WILL THAT BE TREATED I KNOW
THAT THE BILL SPEAKS TO INTENT
LANGUAGE ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS --
AT THE KEEPING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HOLE BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WILL SIT DOWN AND FIGURE OUT
WILL THEY ACTUALLY FOLLOW
THROUGH WITH THAT.
THISBILL DOESN'T HOLD THEIR
HAND TO THAT.
AND IT LEAVES IT OPEN ENDED AND
THAT CONCERN AND UNCERTAINTY IS
OUR CONCERN.
I'M FOR THAT REASON WE JUST
SIMPLY HAVE A PHILOSOPHICAL
DIFFERENCE ABOUT USING THE
EDUCATION FUNNY PAY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THANK.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
DAVID WALL FOR THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN RESPECTING YOU TO
WITNESS SAYS PER OPPOSE.
ASIDE I'LL JUST SAY WE ARE
OPPOSED -- REFLECTING EXACTLY
THE VIEWS THAT MISTER NAYLOR TO
SHARED THANK YOU.
LIVES WITH US WELL THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WE ALSO HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT
THIS WILL HAVE ON SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THANK YOU.
OKAY SHILOH LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WE OPPOSE ON AS
AMENDED.
JENNER JENNIFER BESTER FROM
EDUCATE OUR STATE THERE ARE
NINETEEN COUNTIES WHO'S THE RAF
FUNDS ARE COMPLETELY DEPLETED BY
THE VEHICLE LICENSE FEE SWAP.
THIS WAS NOT MENTIONED IN THIS
THAT MEANS THAT IN THOSE
NINETEEN COUNTIES KERN SAN DIEGO
RIVERSIDE SAN BERNARDINO.
THE FIRST DOLLAR. TO FUND THIS
WILL COME OUT OF DIRECT TAX
ALLOCATION TO SCHOOLS.
IN MY COUNTY SAN MATTEO IT WILL
COME OUT FROM THE POOREST
SCHOOLS.
IT WILL COME OUT FOR THE POOREST
SCHOOLS BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
ONLY ONES THAT RECEIVE LCF OF
FUNDING SO IT WILL COME FROM
REDWOOD CITY.
FROM EAST PALO ALTO FROM DALY
CITY.
IT WILL NOT COME FROM WOULD SIDE.
FROM HILLSBOROUGH FROM RIVERSIDE
FOR THAT MATTER MANY OF THE THE
CITIES THAT HAVE BEEN MENTIONED
HERE PALO ALTO.
DO NOT RECEIVE ANY ELSE HALF OF
FUNDING SO THEY CAN BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THE BACKS
OF THEIR POOREST NEIGHBORS WE
CANNOT KEEP THROWING SCHOOL
CHILDREN.
UNDER THE BUS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET US BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMóN.
THANK YOU I I'D. TO ASK THE
AUTHOR IF YOU CAN RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RELATED TO
THE EDUCATION COMMUNITY WHICH IS
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT TO US -- IN
THE INFORMATION WE SUPPLIED TO
THE COMMITTEE -- BEFORE WE WENT
DOWN THIS ROAD.
WE ASK THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S.
EXAMINE.
HW THE BILL?
IMPACTS SCHOOL FINANCE.
AND THEY HAVE SUBMITTED A
WRITTEN REPORT THAT YOU CAN READ
THAT ACTUALLY INDICATES.
THAT THE BILL WILL HAVE NO
FISCAL IMPACT ON THE SCHOOL
BECAUSE IT'S COMPLETELY BACK
FILLED.
OF THE MONEY IS COMPLETELY BACK
FILLED IN THE IN THE GENERAL
FUND -- ALLOCATION THAT BACK
FEELS THE HE RALPH FUND THAT'S
DIVERTED TO THESE PROGRAMS.
SO IN ESSENCE -- THERE IS NO
IMPACT ON SCHOOLS -- WE ALSO
HAVE -- LOOKED AT THE ISSUE OF
BACK FILLING THE SCHOOLS RATE
REGARDING THE CALCULATION TEST
ONE TEST TO TEST.
THREE IN TERMS OF PROP.
NINETY EIGHT AND WE PUT LANGUAGE
THAT -- HAS AN AUTOMATIC BACK
FILL IN AN AND TELL US ONE YEARS
WHICH IS THE WHEN IT GETS KIND
OF TIGHT -- THE BILL CALLS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE TO RE
BRANCH THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
BACK FILLSO THAT -- ABSOLUTELY
NO DOLLARS ARE LOST TO THE
SCHOOLS.
THE LEGISLATURE ALSO UNDER THIS
BILL THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
GOVERNOR.
CAN'T SUSPEND APPROVAL OF NEW
PLANTS DURING FISCAL DOWNTURNS
WHEN THERE'S A RAINY DAY -- FUND
OR WHEN PROP NINETY EIGHT IS
SUSPENDED SUSPENDED SPECIFICALLY
SAYS THAT YOU CAN.
OF SUSPEND THIS THIS -- PROGRAM.
SO -- WE HAVE PUT THOSE
GUARANTEES IN THE BILL -- I I
THINK DID -- OF GUARANTEEING
THAT -- IS REFERABLE.
TO JUST LETTING -- REDEVELOPMENT
TAX INCREMENTS -- IN.
REDUCE THE PROPERTY TAX AND I
KNOW THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
APPROVED -- BECAUSE I'M ON THE
GOVERNMENT FINANCE COMMITTEE
WHICH IS MADE A FEW MINUTES --
WE HAVE REVIEWED AND APPROVED
SOMETHING LIKE EIGHT OR NINE
BILLS.
THAT ACTUALLY.
DO MUCH MORE PROPERTY TAX
DIVERSION IN THIS BILL BECAUSE
THIS BILL HAS NO PROPERTY TAX
DIVERSION -- THAT WILL NOT BE
BACK FILLED BY THE GENERAL FUND.
SO SO THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHY --
WE PROPOSE THIS BILL SO WE WOULD
GUARANEE THE SCHOOLS FUNDING --
THE OTHER ISSUE MAYBE OF CAN
RESTED EMINENT DOMAIN ISSUE THIS
BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS THE ISSUE
IN A DONE AND WE WE DID NOT
CHANGE THE CURRENT LAW.
ON ANNA DOMAINS WE DID NOT
CREATE -- ANY CHANGES IN IN --
DOMAIN FOR ANY OF THESE ENTITIES --
SO WE DO NOT ADDRESS THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE -- IN THE BILL
AND I THINK THAT -- THE OTHER
ISSUE I WANT TO POINT OUT IS --
IN A DOMAIN HAS BEEN USED.
WHEN OF REDEVELOPMENT STYLE
DEVELOPMENT OCCURS WHEN THEY DO
CLEARING A PROPERTY -- THEY'RE
TRYING TO GET TAX INCREMENTS --
DEVELOPMENTS WITH REDEVELOPMENT
KIND OF PROJECTS THIS BILL DOES
NOT.
FOCUS ON THOSE KINDS OF PROJECTS
THIS BILL FOCUSES ON BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CITIES.
AND COUNTIES AND OTHER ENTITIES
THAT CAN BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SO THIS BILL IS NOT A
REDEVELOPMENT BILL.
IS NOT A TAX INCREMENT FINANCE
BILL IT IS NOT A BILL THAT --
CLEARS LAND AND EMPHASIZES THAT
THIS BILL EMPHASIZES.
BUILDING THE HOUSING IN EXISTING
COMMUNITIES AND BUILDING YOU
KNOW FOR EXAMPLE BUILDING STRONG
NEIGHBORHOODS -- BUILDING -- OF
TRANSIT OR IN DEVELOPMENT INFILL
DEVELOPMENT THOSE KINDS OF
PROJECTS AS OPPOSED TO A
REDEVELOPMENT STYLE.
OF DEVELOPMENT SO I THINK I
THINK READ YOU KNOW I CHAIR THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY IN SAN JOSE.
WE HAD THE SECOND LARGEST
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY IN THE IN
THE IN THE STATE.
AND THIS BILL IS NOT
REDEVELOPMENT.
THIS IS SOMETHING DIFFERENT THIS
IS A NEW APPROACH TO IMPROVING
OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I WILL
NOTE THAT I THINK IN A LOT OF
CASES THESE ARE BOTH COMPELLING
AND COMPETING INTERESTS -- A IN
SOME WAYS BECAUSE IT IS THE SAME
STUDENTS -- THAT I HAVE FOUND AS
A FORMER EDUCATOR AT WHO DON'T
HAVE HOUSING -- SOME OF THE
STUDENTS AT SCHOOLS WITH ELL CFF --
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE LIVING IN
LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS SHARING --
ROOMS IN HOME SO I THINK IT'S
IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT. TO BETTER SERVE --
OUR STUDENTS WE ALSO HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE HOUSING
AND THEIR FAMILIES HAVE HOUSING
AS WELL -- SO I THINK YOU FOR
THE CLARIFICATION THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING AND THE THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS THOUGHTFUL
BILL FORWARD.
COULD YOU AKE A COMMENT ON THE
BONDS BECAUSE THERE WAS SOME
INFERENCE RELATED TO THE BONDS
ON THE LOCAL AGENCIES AND ALSO
THE STATE BONDS -- OKAY.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ENGAGE OR
ALLOW OR CREATE STATE BONDING.
SO HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH STATE
MONNING OKAY -- THIS BILL ALLOWS
FINANCING -- AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
LIKE THE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCES DISTRICT FREE -- ALL
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THOSE
THINGS ALLOW.
THE LOCAL ENTITY TO DO USE THAT
REVENUE SOURCE TO BOND THIS DOES
THE SAME IT SIMPLY ALLOWS IF
THEY WANT TO IN THEIR PLAN.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO IT'S AN OPT
IN KIND OF THING THEY THIS IS --
OPTIONAL.
POPPED IN PROGRAM IF THEY WANT
TO MAKE A PROPOSITION.
THAT -- THE MONEY CAN BE USED
FOR BONDING IT DOES NOT PRECLUDE
THAT.
OKAY SO IT'S IS SERVE AN OPT IN
AND IT'S NOT A MANDATED BONDING
IF THEY CAN USE IT FOR PLEASURE
GO KIND OF PROGRAMS IF THEY
CHOOSE.
THANK YOU AND ALSO NOTE THAT --
SPEAKING ABOUT BOND SEVERAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- ACTUALLY
CHOOSE TO GO OUT FOR BONDS AND
MANY OF SEVERAL YEARS IN A ROW
SO AN EXAMPLE IN MY OFSPECIFIC
DISTRICT I LIVE IN FULLERTON WAY
OF THE NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
THAT'S JUST GONNA OUT FOR A BOND
THE FULLER TEN UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IT'S JUST.
GONE OUT FOR A BOND AND THE
FULLER TEN ELEMENTARY SO THAT'S
THREE SCHOOL DISTRICTS JUST
RIGHT IN MY CITY SO THERE IS NOT
A LACK OF INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GOING OUT FOR BONDS --
SETTLING LEE ON THE EMINENT
DOMAIN AGAIN LOOKING AT MY
COUNTY NORTH ORANGE COUNTY I
KNOW -- AS A LOCAL COUNCIL
MEMBER THAT WAS ALWAYS QUITE.
A THREAT OF YOU WOULD NEVER WANT
TO DO EMINENT DOMAIN DOMAIN.
WE'VE HAD A PROPERTY AND FULLER
TEN WITH LITERALLY A POOL THAT
WAS OWNED BY TWENTY OWNERS AND
IT'S TAKEN TWENTY YEARS TO STILL
NOT BE ABLE TO MOVE THAT
PROPERTY WHICH IS IN A VERY.
UNDERSERVED AREA SO YOU HAVE A
POOL AREA SITTING THERE WITH ITS
LAND WHERE THE COMMUNITIES
WANTED TO MAKE IT INTO A PARK
AND BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN OF
EMINENT DOMAIN IT'S NEVER
HAPPENED THAT'S BEEN TWENTY
YEARS IN THE MAKING.
BUT I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE --
FROM SANTA BARBARA THAT I AM A
THIRTY YEAR C. T. A MEMBER AND
VERY MUCH SUPPORT EVERYTHING WE
CAN DO TO PROTECT EDUCATIONAL
FUNDING AND PRINT AND INVEST IN
EDUCATION ALL.
FUNDING BUT ON THE OTHER HAND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BASIC NEEDS
OF FAMILIES AND WE LOOK AT WHAT
COMES FIRST IF THE FAMILY
DOESN'T HAVE A HOME.
AND THEY CANNOT I HAVE ANY
CERTAINLY OF WHERE THEY'RE GOING
TO BE AT NIGHT WHETHER IT'S ON A
COUCH WHETHER LIVING WITH THREE
OR FOUR FAMILIES IN A ONE TO TWO
BEDROOM.
APARTMENT AND BY THE WAY THAT
HAPPENS IN NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
IN FULLERTON BECAUSE I WORKED IN
AND TAUGHT AT THE HIGHEST TITLE
ONE SCHOOL WITH ALMOST A
THOUSAND OF A SECOND LANGUAGE
LEARNERS.
THEN IT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THAT EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE
EVEN IF WE INVEST WITH LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING BECAUSE WE GOT
TO GET THEM TO SCHOOL.
WE GOT TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
SOMETHING TO EAT WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT IN MANY SCHOOLS I CAN
WEAR A UNIFORM TO GET THERE SO
EVERYTHING THAT COMES WITH
EDUCATION ABOUT READING WRITING
AND MATH.
COME SECONDARY TO YOUR BASIC
NEEDS OF WHERE WE GONNA LIVE THE
SECOND PART OF THAT IS TEACHERS
ARE ALSO PART OF THIS.
NEW -- GROWING COMMUNITY THAT
CANNOT AFFORD HOUSING IN THE
AREAS THEY TEACH WHETHER IT'S
OAKLAND OR SAN FRANCISCO OR
ORANGE COUNTY SO THIS IS NOT --
SIMPLY -- LET'S PUSH THIS ALONG
BECAUSE WE WANT TO DO MORE
HOUSING THIS IS A CRISIS EVERY
SINGLE DAY -- NOT ONLY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO BUT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
EXPERIENCING CRISIS THAT SHOULD
BE NOTED AS A MORAL CRISIS AND
INTEL WE START DOING THE ACTION
THAT IS NECESSARY WE ARE NOT
GOING TO HAVE KIDS SITTING IN
CLASSROOMS.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T EVEN GET
THERE.
AND SO -- WHEN WE HAVE SAID
LOCAL GOVERNMENT?
SCHOOL DISTRICTS NEED TO MAKE
THEIR OWN DISICK DECISIONS THEY
HAVE TO ACCOUNT THAT IF CAN
FAMILIES CANNOT GET THEIR KIDS
TO SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO
PLACE TO CALL HOME.
THEN WE HAVE TO TAKE THIS AS A
PRIORITY AND PERHAPS IT SWITCHES
AROUND ONCE WE MAKE THIS HOUSING
INVESTMENT -- AND WE CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN EDUCATION WE WON'T
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS SO I SUPPORT THIS
AND MOVE THE BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE TO
RUN -- TO PRESENT IN YOUR HOUSE
BUT JUST WANTED TO COMPLIMENT
YOU ON AN EXCELLENT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE HAD ABOUT IT
WOULD ASK TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR.
SOME AMERICAN THE SENATE ABOUT
ONE DAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONVERSATIONS -- ON THE BELL AND
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT -- THE
PROVISION SAID ABOUT ONE OF THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES -- ON PAGE --
TWENTY FOUR ACTUALLY BEGINS ON
PAGE -- TWENTY THREE AND WHAT'S
THE THE THE POWERS OF THE AGENCY --
AND THE THE WITNESS CITED
SUBSECTION G. ANY OTHER ACT
THAT'S NECESSARY TO CARRY OUT A
PROJECT AS POTENTIALLY
ENCOMPASSING EMINENT DOMAIN DO
YOU AGREE WITH THAT
INTERPRETATION [inaudible]
WELL.
WHAT I SAY ABOUT EMINENT DOMAIN
ON THIS IS?
THERE ARE OTHER SECTIONS OF THE
BILL THAT.
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE ISSUE OF
EMINENT DOMAIN SHOULD LOOK OUT?
OF FOR EXAMPLE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THE BILL'S FOCUSES ON BUILDING
IN FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
NOT A BLIGHT OR COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT.
THAT'S NOT THE EMPHASIS OF THIS
BILL IT'S THE FORD ABOUT HOUSING.
THERE ARE SECTIONS OF THIS BILL
THAT ALSO INCLUDE TENANT
PROTECTION SUCH AS ANTI
DISPLACEMENT.
PROTECTIONSOF THIS -- BILL DOES
NOT CHANGE CURRENT STATUTES ON
EMINENT DOMAIN.
OF THAT COULD BE A FULL.
DISCUSSION IF WE WANT TO HAVE
THAT PHILOSOPHICAL DISCUSSION SO
THIS THIS BILL IS SORT OF
NEUTRAL -- ON IT IT DOES PROVIDE.
FINANCING FOR PROJECTS.
AND THE FINANCING OF THE
PROJECTS.
OF WHICH ARE GOOD PROJECTS
HOUSING AND SO FORTH --
CONCEIVABLY COULD USE EMINENT
DOMAIN OKAY.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE TENET
PROTECTIONS IF THE HOUSING IS IN
AN AREA THAT'S TYPICALLY ZONE
RESIDENTIAL.
AND THERE'S PEOPLE LIVING THERE
THERE'S TENER PROTECTIONS IN
ANTI DISPLACEMENT -- CLAUSES IN
THE BILL THAT PROBABLY WOULD
RESULT IN NO EMINENT DOMAIN.
ON THOSE ON THE AND THAT KIND OF
PROJECTS SO IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A
BILL THAT WOULD LIMIT THEM A
DOMAIN BY THOSE MEANS.
SO IT ACTUALLY -- AS OPPOSED TO
OTHER.
TYPES OF FINANCING.
ACTUALLY DISCOURAGES EMINENT
DOMAIN IN MY OPINION OKAY THAT'S
MY ANSWER QUESTIONS DOES NOT
PRECLUDE IT BUT IT DISCOURAGES
IT.
IS CERTAINLY DISCOURAGES AT MORE
THAN OTHER ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT --
STATUES THAT WE HAVE ON THE
BOOKS.
THAT ENCOURAGE -- ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS SO.
WOULD THERE BE A WAY TO MAKE IT
SORT OF MORE EXPLICIT IN THE
BILL THAT -- IS THE APPROVAL OF
PROJECTS -- WILL AT LEAST TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT -- LIMITS ON THE
USE OF EMINENT DOMAIN OR OR
OTHERWISE PUT SAFEGUARDS IN A
PLACE WHERE THEY CAN WE DID THAT
WOULD HAVE A A MAJOR BLOW UP THE
ISSUE AND HAVE A MAJOR.
DISCUSSION.
OF ON ON THE SUBJECT OF AN
INTIMATE.
I THINK -- DO YOU WANT TO HAVE
THE I'VE NEVER SEEN A PROPOSAL
TO DO THAT -- NOBODY'S GIVEN ME
A PROPOSAL TO DO THAT SO I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THE BILL IS REALLY
LIMITED AND DOMAIN -- YOU SHOULD
TAKE IT FOR WHAT IT IS AND
DECIDE ON HOW YOU WANT TO ACT ON
THE BILL [inaudible]
OKAY.
OUR FIRST YEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN A LARA
I ALSO WANT THINKCENTRE BELL FOR
ECHO COMING IN IN IN IN ME WITH
ME YESTERDAY -- BASED ON THE
CONVERSATION THAT THAT -- WE HAD
THIS MORNING -- TESTIMONY FROM A
SEVERAL OF THE WITNESSES THIS
THAT ARE AGAINST THIS BILL --
ICE WILL HAVE SOME CLARIFICATION
BECAUSE OF CENTER YOUR YOU
STATED ON ON MULTIPLE TIMES THAT --
THIS IS NOT -- THIS IS NOT A A
RECREATION OF REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AND THAT IT'S MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOCUS.
BUT THE THE THE OTHER GENTLEMAN
WHO TESTIFIED AGAINST YOUR BILL
SAYS THAT.
ONLY 50% OF THE OF THE OF THE
FINANCING MECHANISM WOULD GO
INTO -- AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
WHICH LEAVE THE OTHER 50% -- TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO DO.
GENTRIFICATION SUPPLY CONTROL OF
WHETHER IT'S FOR A PUBLIC
PROJECT OR OR EIGHT ABA PRIVATE
PROJECT -- AND I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S WHERE -- MY CONCERN COMES
IN BECAUSE IF.
IT WAS 50% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND YOU LEAVE THE OTHER FIFTY
PERCENTS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
TO A TO DO WHAT THEY FEEL LIKE
KILLING AND AND A COMING FROM A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT -- I KNOW THAT
I'M GONNA BE COMPELLED -- AS A
MEMBER OF THE THE CITY COUNCIL
TO GO AND LOOK FOR A CAR
DEALERSHIP OR ANY KIND OF OF
SALES TAX.
GENERATING.
IS IS IS AND AND AND WERE
CONCERNED THAT WITHOUT WILL --
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN YOUR BILL
THAT WOULD AT LEAST -- PRE VET
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FROM.
THE SIZING AMADOR ME.
OF FOR A TO TO TO TAKE PROPERTY
AWAY FROM ONE OF PRIVATE ENTITY
TO GIVE TO ANOTHER ONE FOR
COMMERCIAL USE.
OF THAT'S THAT THAT'S OUR
CONCERN AND AND AND AND I KNOW
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS OF RIGHT HERE --
BUT THAT'S TO SOMETHING THAT I
FELT REALLY TO SHARE WITH YOU AS
TO WHY I WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY.
THE JUST JUST A CORRECTION IF I
COULD -- THE BILL HAS FIVE
PURPOSES OF THE BILL --
INDICATES THAT A MINIMUM OF 50%
OF THE FUNDS WILL BE USED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THEN THERE'S
FIVE SEPARATE CATEGORIES THAT
THE MONEY CAN BE USED -- FOR
THREE OF THE FIVE CATEGORIES
RELATE TO HOUSING AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OKAY.
SO -- GENERALLY THE ESTIMATE
THAT MOST PEOPLE HAVE LOOKED AT
THE BILL HAVE ANALYZE IT THEY
BELIEVE BELIEVE THAT ABOUT.
7075% OF THE EXPENDITURES OVER
TIME ON THIS BILL WILL BE SPENT
ON HOUSING OKAY.
AND THEN THE SECOND THING I LIKE
TO POINT OUT IS THAT IF YOU'RE
CITY.
HAS FAILED TO ACHIEVE ITS
HOUSING GOALS.
THERE IS ALSO A PROVISION IN THE
BILL.
THAT YOU CAN ONLY OUT OF THE
FIVE CATEGORIES YOU CAN ONLY
SPEND ON THREE OF THE CATEGORIES.
AND THOSE THREE CATEGORIES ARE
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CATEGORIES.
SO IT ACTUALLY IF YOU HAVE NOT
COMPLIED.
WITH YOUR HOUSING GOALS.
YOU HAVE TO SPEND IT ONLY ON THE
HOUSING CATEGORIES.
SO SO -- I THINK IT IT ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGES -- OUR CITIES AND
OTHER GOVERNMENT ENTITIES TO
COMPLETE.
THERE ARE HOUSING --
REQUIREMENTS.
AND THAT'S WHY THAT BILL WAS
ADDED IN YOUR RESPECTIVE
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE WE WE
INCLUDE THOSE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE.
SO THANK YOU.
HEATHER QUESTIONS.
CENTER I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR
COMMITTEE ON THIS -- AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY AM
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO AROUND.
INCREASING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING
PARTICULARLY IN THE WAKE OF HOW
MANY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WE LOST
AFTER THE GREAT RECESSION AND
THE DEMISE OF OF REDEVELOPMENT --
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CREATIVE APPROACH YOU'VE TAKEN
WITH THIS BILLS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
A A BILL WITH -- WITH ANALOGOUS --
GOALS -- AND INTERESTS ARE AB
ELEVEN BILL -- AND TO LOOK FOR
MORE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT.
THE ONLY THING I'LL MENTION IS --
THERE IS A PORTION OF THE
ANALYSIS THAT RAISES.
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT WE
RECEIVED -- AND I'M SURE YOU
HAVE AS WELL ABOUT WHETHER THE
BOND MARKET WILL FIND -- THE
STRUCTURE SECURE ENOUGH TO
SUPPORT ISSUE IN DEBT I THINK IT
IS WORTH CONVERSATIONS IN BOTH
OF OUR HOUSES WE TRY TO ENGAGE
IN THESE IDEAS -- WITH ENSURING.
THAT WERE ACTUALLY ON A TOOT
TOOT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE BOND
MARKETS TO REACT TO WHAT WE ARE
DOING.
UP MY HOPE IS IN THE NEAR TERM
WITH THE APPROACH IS THAT WE
HAVE MOVED FOR FROM THIS
COMMITTING YOURS WE CAN FIND
WAYS FOR BOTH OF THESE
APPROACHES TO COMPLEMENT EACH
OTHER.
OUTLOOK FOR TO THAT UP WITH THAT --
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY A
LESSER ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
THANK YOU THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
WITH THE BILL IN A SECOND ANY
FINAL COMMENTS CENTER.
I VOTE ON THE BILL MADAM
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE IN THE
FUTURE MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY --
COMEDIAN LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHIU.
CHIU I DATE.
NO THE NOW GABRIELLE.
GLORIA GLORIA I KILEY.
CONS NONE MORNING HOLLY MON.
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI THREE VOTES YOU
NEED -- FIVE WILL WAIT FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS I KNOW YOU HAVE A
SECOND ITEM -- FILE ITEM SIX SB.
TWO EIGHTY TWO BACK TO YOU
[inaudible]
WELL.
SWITCHING -- KIND OF THE HOUSING
ISSUE.
TO ANOTHER SUBJECT THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT -- ESPYS TWO EIGHTY
TWO CRATES THE SUPPORT OF
HOUSING FOR PERSONS ON PAROLE
PROGRAM TO SERVE INDIVIDUALS ON
PAROLE.
WITH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND
ALSO FACING HOMELESSNESS WE HAVE --
A STUDIES MANY STUDIES THAT --
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE TEN TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS PEOPLE ON PAROLE
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS ARE
SEVEN TIMES MORE LIKELY. TO
RECIDIVISTS GO BACK INTO
CRIMINAL JUSTICE BEHAVIOR OF IF
THEY ARE NOT HOUSE VERSUS THOSE
THAT OUR HOUSE.
OF SUPPORT OF HOUSING IS IS A
PROVEN METHOD OF REDUCING
RECIDIVISM.
SO IF HOUSING KEEPS PEOPLE FROM
GOING BACK TO PRISON WE SHOULD
TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT THAT.
AND WE'VE TRIED WE STARTED THIS
PROGRAM IS MADE OF WHICH IS
CALLED THE INTEGRATED SERVICES
WERE MENTALLY ILL PAROLEES.
IN IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN
HOWEVER THE CURRENT PROGRAM IS
NOT IN LINE WHAT WAS THE
ORIGINAL LEGISLATIVE INTENT.
IN 200-018-30050 PARTICIPANTS
AND IS ONE OF ONLY THREE PEOPLE
WERE HOMELESS AND THE HOUSING
THAT THE OR PROVIDED THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM IS VERY TEMPORARY.
HOUSING.
SO WE HAVE A UCLA STUDY IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THAT
FOUND THE THIS PROGRAM TO FAIL
IT FAILS TO SECRETLY REDUCE
RECIDIVISM.
AND THAT'S CONTINUE TO BE
VALIDATED AS WE OVER OVER TIME.
SO -- THE PROGRAM ACTUALLY --
PROVIDES AN AVERAGE OF TEN
MONTHS OF TREATMENT ON AVERAGE
BEFORE PEOPLE ARE DROPPING OUT
OF THE PROGRAM -- THE THE THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTION SHOES
USES THIS PROGRAM TO PAY
ESSENTIALLY A 100% OF THE COST
OF MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT.
INSTEAD OF A ROLLING THEM AND
MEDICARE ALL WHICH IS THE COMMON
THING THAT HAPPENS NOW WITH FOR
ALL THESE.
AND THEY CAN DRAW DOWN A FEDERAL
MATCH. FOR ONE DOLLAR THEY GET A
DOLLAR AND FEDERAL FUNDS AT
LEAST.
SO IT DOES NOT MAKE A FISCAL
SENSE TO CONTINUE FUNDING THE
PROGRAM.
THAT A 100%.
IS USED FOR MEDICINE WHEN WE CAN
GET THEM MORE ALMOST EVERY
PERSON LEAVING.
OUR STATE FACILITIES ARE
ELIGIBLE -- FOR MEDI CAL -- THIS
BILL RE DIRECTS THE PROGRAM TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
COMMUTE DEVELOPMENT TO PARTNER
WITH COUNTIES TO ENSURE
PARTICIPANTS CAN ACCESS.
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND OTHER
HEALTH CARE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT THROUGH MEDI CAL.
AND BY REQUIRING COUNTIES TO
UTILIZE MEDI CAL.
UNDER THE CURRENT -- PROGRAM WE
ARE DRAWING DOWN FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS WE ACTUALLY GET
MORE MONEY.
INTO THIS SERVICE.
THERE BY DIRECTING THE PROGRAMS
FUNDING TOWARDS SUPPORT OF
HOUSING -- AND ITS STRUCTURE TO
USE STATE DOLLARS IN THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE WAY.
REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND PER PRO
PROPOSE -- INTEGRATION AND
REDUCE CRIME IN THE COMMUNITY I
REGION I VOTE WE HAVE SOME
WITNESSES SURE RAPPAPORT IS THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING.
AND WE HAVE SOMEBODY FROM THE
ANTI.
RECIDIVISM COALITION OKAY SO
TURNED OUT OF MY WITNESSES
[inaudible]
YOUR WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING ASSURING REPORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT
REALLY IS ABOUT USING EXISTING
STATE RESOURCES MORE WISELY --
EVIDENCE SHOWS SUPPORT OF
HOUSING WHICH IS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITH INTENSIVE SERVICES --
BREAKS THE LINK BETWEEN
INCARCERATION AND AND
HOMELESSNESS THE LINK THAT
SENATOR BELL DESCRIBES SO WELL --
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAVE FUNDED
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING -- PEOPLE ON PAROLE
OR PROBATION.
AND HAVE FOUND THAT IT IMPROVES
A FORMALLY CARS RATED
INDIVIDUALS CHANCES OF STAYING
OUT OF PRISON RECOVERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS AND ACCESSING
TREATMENT FOR BOTH MENTAL
ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE USE.
AS ONE EXAMPLE OHIO CREATED AS
PART OF HOUSING PROGRAM FOR
PEOPLE ON PAROLE WHO ARE LIKELY
TO BECOME HOMELESS UPON RELEASE
FROM PRISON.
AND THEY HAVE FOUND.
THAT 40% REDUCTION IN THE DAYS
SPENT INCARCERATED AND OVER 60%
REDUCTION AND RE ARRESTS AMONG --
AYE PARTICIPANTS AS COMPARED TO
A CONTROL GROUP.
PARTICIPANTS WERE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO PARTICIPATE AND MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT IF THEY WERE
LIVING IN SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
SIMILARLY AND NEW YORK PROGRAM
FOR PEOPLE CYCLING BETWEEN --
REIKERS ICLOUD ISLAND AND
HOMELESS SHELTERS FOUND SUPPORT
OF HOUSING NOT ONLY REDUCE
RECIDIVISM RATES SIGNIFICANTLY
TO STATE AND LOCAL COSTS.
AND HEALTH CARE AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE SYSTEMS.
PARTICIPANTS WERE LESS LIKELY TO
ABUSE SUBSTANCES AND MORE LIKELY
TO RECOVER FROM MENTAL ILLNESS
IN THIS PROGRAM AGAIN AS
COMPARED TO A CONTROL GROUP.
AND DOZENS OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
HAVE FOUND SIMILAR RESULTS.
SB TWO EIGHTY TWO WILL NOT ONLY
PROVIDE THIS EVIDENCE BASED
MODEL TO SOLVE HOMELESSNESS FOR
PEOPLE I'M PRO.
IT WILL CONTINUE TO CONNECT
PEOPLE TO MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AND DO SO IN A WAY
THAT -- ALLOWS PEOPLE TO
CONTINUE MENTAL TREATMENT AND
NOT HAVE A BREAK AND THEIR
TREATMENT AS THE CURRENT PROGRAM --
I'VE DOES NOT ALLOW -- EVEN
THOUGH THE STATE WILL NO LONGER
USE IS MET DOLLARS PAY FOR
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT SUPPORT
TO NOTE THAT UNDER THE NEW
PROGRAM UNDER SB.
TWO EIGHTY TWO PEOPLE WOULD
STILL BE RECEIVING MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AND AGAIN WE DO FEEL
LIKE THIS MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT BE BETTER US FAR
SUPERIOR TO THE TREATMENT
THEY'RE RECEIVING NOW.
I SECOND THE MOTION -- SB TWO
EIGHTY TWO WILL ESTABLISH AN
EFFECTIVE EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACH TO REDUCING RECIDIVISM
AMONG CALIFORNIANS MOST LIKELY
TO RESET OF EIGHT IT WILL NOT
ONLY TRANSFORM THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO HOUSING NEEDS AMONG
PEOPLE ON PAROLE BUT REDUCE AND
EQUITIES AND OUR SYSTEM IN OUR
RESPONSE TO HOMELESSNESS.
I THEREFORE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA SECOND BY OUR VICE CHAIR
MISTER DO [inaudible] FOR MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY BEFORE YOU TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILLS TWO
EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS JOHN
MCLAUGHLIN I'M THE HOUSING
DIRECTOR FOR THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION.
THEY ARE SEE IS A SUPPORT
NETWORK FOR AND COMPRISED OF
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS DEVOTED TO CHANGING
THEIR LIVES BY BECOMING LEADERS
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AIR SHE CURRENTLY SERVES OVER
ONE THOUSAND MEMBERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FIVE
YEARS AGO WE ASKED OUR MEMBERS
WHAT THEY NEEDED MOST WHEN
RETURNING HOME.
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING OR AT THE
TOP OF THAT LIST.
THEY ARE SHE DECIDED OPEN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING SITE AND SOME
ARE IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN WE STARTED WITH
THIRTY TWO BEDS AND SINCE THEN
HAVE DOUBLE THAT NUMBER TO SIXTY
FOUR WHEN WE OPENED OUR SECOND
SIDE LOS ANGELES.
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES WERE BUILT
INTO OUR HOUSING PROGRAM FROM
THE START EACH MEMBER IS
ASSIGNED A LIFE COACH WHO
PROVIDES CASE MANAGEMENT AND
MENTORSHIP.
OUR LIFE COACHES ARE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED PROVIDING LIVED
EXPERIENCE FOR PARTICIPANTS.
WE ALSO PROVIDE THE LIFE SKILLS
WORKSHOPS THAT FOCUS ON
FINANCIAL LITERACY HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS AND CAREER
READINESS FOR STARTERS.
UPON EMPLOYMENT THEY MAINTAIN
REGULAR DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
SAVINGS WITH MINIMUM DEPOSITS
BASED ON BUDGETS AND GOALS.
THIS IS ALL FOR A FOCUSED EXIT
PLAN WHEN THEY LEAVE THE SUPPORT
OF HOUSING.
OUR HOUSING PARTICIPANTS OFTEN
COME TO US EXPRESSING ANXIETY
OVER RE ENTERING THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
AIR SEE SUPPORT OF HOUSING
PROGRAM EXISTS TO PROVIDE A SAFE
LIVING ENVIRONMENT WITH THE
SUPPORT OF THE SOLID SUPPORT
SYSTEM.
THAT ALLOWS OUR MEMBERS TO FOCUS
ON THE REINTEGRATION.
OUR LIFE COACHES WALK THEM
THROUGH EVERY STEP OF OUR
HOUSING PROGRAM IS THE PROVIDE
SERVICES TO ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS.
THE LOS ANGELES HAVING SAY THE
LOS ANGELES HOUSING SERVICES
AUTHORITY WHICH TRACK STATISTICS
ON OUR OUTCOMES WERE REPORTED
THAT DURING TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
1980% OF OUR EXITED PARTICIPANTS
MOVED ON TO PERMANENT HOUSING.
WITH THE LESS THAN 10%
RECIDIVISM RATE AMONGST OUR
HOUSING PARTICIPANTS WE BELIEVE
THIS TO BE A SUCCESSFUL MODEL.
THAT IS WHY A OUR SHE STRONGLY
SUPPORTS ON THE BILL TWO EIGHTY
TWO A SIMILAR MODEL WITH THE
SAME GOAL FOCUSED ON SUPPORT OF
HOUSING.
HOUSING BASED SERVICES AND
WRAPAROUND CARE FOR AN EVEN MORE
VULNERABLE POPULATION.
INDIVIDUALS ON PAROLE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
WE NEED THESE PROGRAMS IN ORDER
FOR FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ALREADY FACING
COUNTLESS BARRIERS UPON RE ENTRY
TO SUCCESSFULLY REINTEGRATE INTO
THE COMMUNITIES.
REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND INCREASED
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I RESPECTFUL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU ARE
THERE OTHER SUPPORTERS OF THE
BILL.
THE MORNING DELYLAH CLAMOR HALF
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
I'M NOT OVERAWED WITH CHRIS
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
LOUIS MANTE WITH CALIFORNIA BEEN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
MORNING MR CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE A
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MENDOZA WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COLLISION IS STRONG
SUPPORT.
CHRISTOPHER MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
POLICY LINCOLN HOUSING
CALIFORNIA COSPONSORED IN
SUPPORT.
FILL THE ASSEMBLY SEAN BEHALF
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND SUPPORT.
TIME HERE IN THE WITH THE COUNTY
PAPER HOUSE DIRECTORS THOSE
ASIAN SUPPORT TICKET.
A DRIVER LESS WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
GUYS CAN LET THE OTHER PEOPLE
[inaudible]
SIR.
THE TO STATE YOUR STEVEN WEBER
OUT WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES -- IT
YOUR EXPRESSED CONCERNS THAT I
WE WILL BE CLEAR THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THE INTENT AND
SUPPORT THE IDEA OF USING
COUNTIES TO DRAW DOWN TO MISTER
MOORE.
DRIED UP IT'LL DOLLARS MISTER
MORE COVERAGE OF HOUSING SUPPORT
FOR MENTALLY ILL PAROLEES -- WE
ARE CONCERNED HOWEVER ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL DISPLACEMENT OF STATE
WORKERS WHO CURRENTLY MINISTER
THE CURRENT IS MISS PROGRAM.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
OF FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH US TO CRAFT A SOLUTION TO
PROTECT PUBLIC WORKERS IN BETTER
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THOSE IN
NEED.
THANK YOU.
I YES -- MY NAME IS JAMES
SWEENEY I'M WITH THE ARE BLACK
AMERICAN POLITICAL ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA.
I'VE BEEN A FORMER APPOINTEE OF
THE LAST THREE GOVERNOR'S
WORKING WITH PEOPLE -- WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES -- THE IS A
MATH PROGRAM.
THAT IS A PROGRAM FOR THE
SEVERELY CHRONICALLY MENTALLY
ILL.
AND IT IS NOT ONLY A QUESTION OF
JUST SAYING HOUSING FIRST.
THERE ARE MANY PROBLEMS.
AND THE AVERAGE PER RIDER OF
HOUSING WHO HAS NOT DEALT WITH
THIS POPULATION.
BOB WE BELIEVE THIS POSES A
MAJOR PROBLEM.
AND WE THINK THAT THE BRIDGE HAS
NOT BEEN BUILT TO JUST SAY
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE VERY VERY
STRONG SUPPORT.
AND IT IS ALSO ONE OF THE
NOTIONS IN THE BILL INDICATES
THAT IT.
FOLKS SHOULD GET MEDIC COW
CERTAIN COUNTIES ARE NOT
PROVIDING MEDIC COW FOR THIS
POPULATION.
AND SO THE IT'S IT'S IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT AND IT IS
ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT --
IN STE IN THOSE COUNTIES WHERE
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWING THIS KIND
OF FUNDING.
IT ALSO REQUIRES A 10% COUNTY
MATCH.
AND SO WE THINK THAT.
ARE WHILE THE END TO IT.
OUR IS STRONG AND GOOD AND WE
SUPPORT THE INTERNET WE DO NOT
SUPPORT THAT.
FINALLY -- THIS IS ONE OF THE
FEW PROGRAMS WHERE THERE ARE
MINORITIES AND AFRICAN AMERICANS
WHO ARE PLAYING A VERY CRITICAL
ROLE IN DEALING WITH THIS
POPULATION.
AND TO **** THE CONTRACT FROM
CDC ARE -- WE THINK IS NOT.
THE BEST THING TO DO.
SO WE ARE IN EFFECT WE OPPOSE
THE LEGISLATION.
IF I COULD JUST AS A QUESTION
THERE WERE NO LETTERS OF
OPPOSITIONSUBMITTED TO THIS
COMMITTEE SO ARE YOU YOU ARE
POSING THE BILLARE.
OKAY ASKED ME AS AS WELL
[inaudible]
YES OKAY.
AND JUST TO CLARIFY WERE LETTERS
I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU DIDN'T GET
THEM I HAVE ADDITIONAL COPIES
HAPPY FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
RECEIVE AND WE JUST DIDN'T
RECEIVE THEM BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WAS DONE.
OKAY LET ME ASK IF THERE OTHER
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO
POST AVAIL MYSELF.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS A MARVIN
ALL THE ON THE CLINICAL DIRECTOR
AT ONE OF THE IS THE PROVIDERS.
AND I WANTED TO KIND OF POINT
OUT THAT THE DATA THAT.
SENATE BILL HAS IDENTIFIED WITH
THE UCLA STUDY OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHICH WAS ACTUALLY --
CONDUCTED IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND THAT WAS PRIOR TO
CDC ARE STREAMLINING THE ECLIPSE --
SERVICES AND IDENTIFYING FIFTEEN
DOMAIN AREAS WITH HOUSING BEING
ONE OF THEM SO THE UCLA CAME OUT
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN TO
CONDUCT THIS STUDY BUT THE DATA
WAS NOT PUBLISHED UNTIL.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
ADDITIONALLY -- I LIKE. TO POINT
OUT THAT THE THE CORE ISSUE OF
THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
HOUSING FOR SEVERELY MENTALLY
ILL OFFENDERS AND THE QUESTION
TO THE COMMITTEE IS HOW DO
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL OFFENDERS
BECOME HOMELESS.
IT'S BECAUSE OF THAT MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES SO A LIFE COACH
WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THAT
YOU'LL NEED TO HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT WE ARE ONE OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH -- IS THE
PROVIDERS WE WE PROVIDE BOTH
MENTAL HEALTH AND HOUSING
SERVICES.
IN TERMS OF COST -- COST
VARIATIONS IT COST ABOUT EIGHTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
TO HOUSE A MENTALLY ILL OFFENDER
IN THE INSTITUTION SETTING AND
THAT THIS MAP SERVICES THAT WE
OFFER RIGHT NOW IS FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR. FOR A
PERSON TO RECEIVE THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE CARE AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS DOLLARS A
YEAR TO INCLUDE MENTAL HEALTH
AND HOUSING.
BUT THE BILL SAYS THAT IT'S
GOING TO PAY UP. TO TWO TO THREE
YEARS FOR THEM TO BE HOUSE -- AT
MARKET RATES THAT TWO TIMES THE
MARKET RATE THE RENT BEING TWO
TIMES THE MARKET RATE I DON'T
KNOW HOW THAT'S A COST SAVINGS.
FOR THE FOR THE PUBLIC IT IS
GOING TO COST AS IN THIS WE
RECREATING THE WHEEL SPEND MORE
MONEY AND RECREATE THE WHEEL.
THE SURGEON GENERAL OF
CALIFORNIA HAS IDENTIFIED TRAUMA
AS BEING ONE OF THE CORE
COMPONENTS OF THE HISTORICAL
DRAMAS OF GOKULCOMPONENT OF
CURRENT ISSUES FOR A FENDER BASS
POPULATION HI ACES AND
RESILIENCY AS PART OF OUR
IDENTIFICATION PROCESS TO
IDENTIFY TRAUMA.
AND LINK THEM WITH SERVICES AND
WITH A SUPPORTIVE HOUSING BILL
IT DOESN'T IDENTIFY.
THOSE INTENSIVE TREATMENT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT SEVERELY MENTALLY
ILL POPULATION.
YOU CAN JUST PROVIDE THEM WITH
HOUSING AND LIFE COACHES TO SAY
OKAY THIS IS GOING TO BE THE KEY
YOU HAVE A SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL
POPULATION WHICH MEANS THAT.
THEY NEED COMPREHENSIVE CARE AND
HOUSING.
SENATE BILL SAID THAT -- TALK
ABOUT THAT -- A 100% OF THE
FUNDS IS BEING USED TO PAY FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
AND OF MEDICINE WE DON'T PAY FOR
ANY MEDICINE -- ALL OF THE BILL
DOES NOT UTILIZE ANY DOLLARS FOR
MEDICINE I AT LEAST IN OUR
PROGRAM IN SACRAMENTO AND FRESNO --
WE PAY FULL HOUSING SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING -- WE PAY FOR MENTAL
HEALTH CARE -- WE PAY.
FOR LIFE SKILLS AS WELL AS TO BE
ABLE TO TEACH THEM SELF
SUFFICIENCY SKILL TO BE ABLE TO
BE INDEPENDENT SO WHAT HAPPENS
IF THIS BILL PASSES.
AND THREE YEARS THEY'VE BEEN
HOUSE WHAT'S AFTER THAT HOW TO
DIP A PASS ON THE BATON FOR THE
THESE POPULATION TO BE SELF
SUFFICIENT AND INDEPENDENT.
THEY DON'T HAVE THOSE BASIC
SKILLS AND THAT'S WHAT WE REALLY
NEED TO DO.
SO WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT OPPOSE THE BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND THE
FACT THAT YOU ARE POSING THANK
YOU.
THERE ARE THOMAS QUALITY FAMILY
SERVICES AND AM I'M OPPOSING.
IF I MAY MAY I WE'VE ACTUALLY
HEARD THREE THREE WITNESSES WE
TYPICALLY HAVE TO SO JUST ASK
YOU TO JUST STATE THE FACT YOU
OPPOSE.
AND THAT'S THE PROCESS FAMILY
QUALITY SERVICE I OPPOSE.
WILLIAM R. BESIDE THEIR FAMILY
QUALITY SERVICES ARE POSSIBLE.
TAJ UPON GO FAMILY QUALITY
SERVICES I OPPOSE.
W. LOPEZ FROM QUALITY FAMILY
SERVICES I ALSO.
HE HAD A NAME FROM QUALITY
FAMILY SERVICES AND I OPPOSE.
HEY BECAUSE OURS FROM QUALITY
FAMILY SERVICES OPPOSE. FOR
MONTHS IBERIAN CCS I OPPOSE.
I NEED A FERNANDEZ QUALITY
FAMILY SERVICES I OPPOSE.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION.
SENATE APPRECIATE BOTH YOUR LONG
TERM COMMITMENT ON THIS ISSUE
OVER THE YEARS AS WELL AS THE
APPROACH THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING I
THINK I'D DEFINITELY SUPPORT --
CHANGING UP THE PARADIGM FROM
WHAT IT HAS BEEN WHICH THE DATA
THAT WE DO HAVE IS NOT -- BEEN
WHERE I THINK WE WANT TO BE AND
DOESN'T DRAW DOWN ON FEDERAL
MATCHES TO MOVE IN IT -- WITHIN
EACH CD WHICH I DO THINK IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE AND TO TO TO OPERATE
THESE PROGRAMS AND TO TO REALLY
EXPAND AND AND SHIFT THE
PARADIGM OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DEAL WITH SO WITH THAT I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WAS SUPPORTING THIS
TODAY.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND ANY FINAL
COMMENTS WOULD YOU IF IF IF IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION I THINK
THAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL -- RECENT
CHECKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS.
INDICATES THAT -- THE CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST POSITION -- THERE
WERE SEVEN HUNDRED NINETYFOUR
POSITIONS BUDGETED [inaudible]
AND CURRENTLY ONLY SIX HUNDRED
AND FORTY NINE WERE FILLED.
SO WE'RE HAVING A HARD TIME.
ACTUALLY GETTING STAFF WHERE DO
WE HAVE A A HUNDRED FORTY SIX
VACANCIES WERE.
FIND TO RECRUIT PEOPLE.
BUT I THINK FOR THIS PROGRAM SO
THERE IS AN A THE ISSUE ABOUT.
STAFF LOSING THEIR JOBS OR ANY
OF THAT KIND OF THERE ISN'T
THAT'S NOT AN ISSUE.
SO SO -- I THINK THE ISSUE IS
THE CONTRACTORS I KNOW THE
CONTRACTORS ARE NOW GOING TO
HAVE TO WORK WITH.
ANOTHER AGENCY -- AND I HOPE
THEY DO BECAUSE THEY HAVE
VALUABLE STAFF AND SERVICES THAT
CAN BE PROVIDED BUT WE NEED TO
HAVE A BETTER FINANCING PLAN.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES --
ISSUE POINTED OUT I REGION I
VOTE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS TWO BY
TWO I DEEP.
GET FREE -- VOTE ON THIS MORNING
HI SORRY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP I GABRIEL
GLORIA KILEY.
KILEY I REMIND.
REMIND I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA
YOUR FOR VOTE TO NEED ONE MORE
TO GET OUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
NEXT ITEM SENATOR HILL SB SIX
SEVENTY TWO LINE ITEM ELEVEN ON
BRISBANE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- GOOD
MORNING AS I'M SURE YOU ARE
AWARE OF IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE VOTERS IN THE CITY
OF BRISBANE MADE A SIGNIFICANT
COMMITMENT. TO REGIONAL HOUSING
WHEN THEY APPROVED THE MEASURE
JJ WHICH WOULD PERMIT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
TO TWENTY TWO HUNDRED UNITS OF
HOUSING ON THE BAY LANCE PROJECT --
LAND IN BRISBANE THIS WOULD MORE
THAN DOUBLE MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
HOUSING STOCK IN BRISBANE.
PASSING MEASURE JJ WAS A
WATERSHED MOMENT FOR BRISBANE IN
THE STATE.
MEASURE JJ REVERSES NEARLY FIFTY
YEARS OF VOTES AGAINST
DEVELOPMENT OF THE BAY LANDS IT
REPRESENTS THE TYPE OF LOCAL
LEADERSHIP WE NEED THROUGHOUT
THE BAY AREA.
AND THE STATE IF WE ARE GOING TO
PUT A REAL DENT IN THE HOUSING
CRISIS.
GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
REMEDIATION AND DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS BRISBANE WILL BE WORKING
FOR MANY YEARS IN COORDINATION
WITH THE DEVELOPER THE STATE AND
REGIONAL AGENCIES.
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO KEEP
THIS PROJECT ON TRACK SB SIX
SEVENTY TWO ALLOWS BRISBANE TO
FOCUS ITS EFFORTS ON GETTING THE
BAY LANDS.
IN IMPORTANT REGIONAL PROJECT
THE BILL DOES THIS BY INSURING
CONSISTENCY IN BRISBANE'S
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS OF
ALLOCATIONS.
DURING THIS PLANNING CYCLE AND
THE NEXT.
IN RECOGNITION OF THIS
COMMITMENT ALREADY MADE.
BY THE CITY'S VOTERS TO DOUBLE
ITS HOUSING STOCK.
SB SIX SEVENTY TWO IS NOT A GIFT.
THAT IS THE BENEFIT TO BRISBANE
UNDER THE BILL IS ONLY AVAILABLE
AT THE CITY CONTINUES TO MAKE
STEADY PROGRESS WITH THE BAIL AS
DEVELOPMENT UNDER THE OVERSIGHT.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOP DEVELOPMENT I
DO HAVE A WITNESS IN SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
YOUR WITNESS -- GOOD MORNING --
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME'S JOHN SWEETIE AND THE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR
FOR THE CITY OF BRISBANE BEEN
THERE FOR ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS
AND I OVERSEE THE COMMUNITY
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS WITHIN THE CITY.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
TODAY IN FAVOR OF THE BILL --
COMMITTEE OF SENATOR HILL DID A
GOOD JOB OF REPRESENTING THE
HISTORY OF THIS PROJECT -- AND
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO THE
CITY AND THE REGION I WOULD LIKE
TO POINT OUT AS THEBRISBANE
MAYOR MADISON DAVIS WROTE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THE PROMISE OF MEASURE JJ CAN
ONLY BE REALIZED THAT THE CITY
CAN PRIORITIZE IMPLEMENTING THE
VOTER APPROVED PLAN AND AVOID
DISTRACTION FROM CONFUSION ABOUT
THE PLAN -- SB SIX SEVENTY TWO
WILL PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE CITY AND THE COMMUNITY. TO
FOCUS A ITS ATTENTION TIME AND
RESOURCES ON THIS VERY
COMPLICATED AND IMPORTANT
PROJECT TO BOTH THE CITY AND THE
REGION -- TO INTERACT WITH THE
STATE REGULATORS WILL HAVE AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN OVERSEEING THE
HAZARDOUS -- REMEDIATION OF THE
SITE AND OTHER STATE AND
REGIONAL AGENCIES WILL HAVE THE
INPUT AND OVERSIGHT OF THIS
PROJECT -- WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SB SIX SEVENTY TWO I MOVE THE
BILL HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE THANK YOU.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION -- SINCE
THERE ARE NO OTHER MEMBERS ARE
HAPPY TO SECOND IT.
OUR OTHER SUPPORTERS OF THE
MEASURE IS SERVICE CHAIR MEMBERS
JASON RILEY CALIFORNIA CITIES WE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I
WANT TO THANK THE GOOD SENATOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
THIS IS A DEVELOPMENT -- IN
QUESTION THAT HAS BEEN CLOSELY
WATCHED THROUGHOUT THE BAY.
INCLUDING BY MY CONSTITUENTS AND
I THINK EVER SINCE A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO WHEN THE FORMER MAYOR
OF BRISBANE.
SUGGESTED THAT BRISBANE OUGHT TO
SUPPORT SIGNIFICANT COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT -- BUT SUGGESTED
THAT ALL OF THOSE WORKERS COULD
LIVE IN MY CITY IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHICH IS NOT A COMET THAT WENT
OVER PRACTICALLY WELL FOR SAN
FRANCISCO -- WERE HAPPY TO SEE
THE HOUSING THAT'S BEEN NOW
PROPOSED ON THE SITE AND
APPRECIATE THE CARROT AND STICK
APPROACH IN THIS BILL WITH THAT
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT.
ALSO SUPPORTED BY A VICE CHAIR
ANY FINAL COMMENTS AND
RECREATION I VOTED THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CHU CHU I DEEP.
DEEP I GABRIEL GLORIA KILEY LEE
MON MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA WILL
WAIT FOR EVERYONE TO GET BACK
IT'S A BUSY MORNING THANK YOU TO
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU SENATOR.
SENATOR DODD.
FILE ITEM FOR SB.
TWO SEVENTY FOUR THE SELLING
THEM BE ALONE [inaudible]
I DO.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS --
FIRST I WANT TO THANK COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK IN
HELPING CRAFT AMENDMENTS FOR
THIS BILLS GOT A BROUGHT
EVERYBODY TOGETHER.
I'LL BE ACCEPTING ALL THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS --
CALIFORNIA HAS A HOUSING CRISIS
WE KNOW THAT WE NEED MORE
HOUSING.
AND WITH THE HIGHEST HOME PRICES
IN THE CONTINENTAL UNITED STATES
WE NEED MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
MOBILE HOMES ARE ONE OF THE FEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS WE
HAVE -- THIS BILL HELPS TO KEEP
THAT SORT OF HOUSING AFFORDABLE
AND HELPS KEEP SENIORS AND
DISABLED PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES.
FIRST THIS BILL CLARIFIES A
COMPANION LANGUAGE FROM MY TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SB. ONE FOUR
SEVEN SB ONE FOUR SEVEN PROVIDED
FOR MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS WHO
LIVE ALLOWED TO BE ABLE TO
DESIGNATE A COMPANION TO LIVE
WITH THEM WITHOUT A FEAT.
SOME PARK OWNERS HAVE
INTERPRETED -- THE ONE COMPANION
PER YEAR AS OF ONE COMPANION
TOTAL PER YEAR THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THAT A RESUME HAVE ONE
COMPANION.
AT A TIME UP TO THREE PER
CALENDAR YEAR.
SECOND OF A MOBILE HOME PARK IS
DESTROYED BY WILDFIRE OR OTHER
NATURAL DISASTER THIS BILL WOULD
OFFER PREVIOUS HOMEOWNERS THE
FIRST OFFER TO LIVE IN THE PARK
IF IT IS REBUILT.
AS WE SEE YEAR ROUND FIRE SEASON
GLOBAL WARMING LEADING TO
NUMEROUS CHANGES IN WEATHER
PATTERNS NATURAL DISASTERS WILL
BECOME EVEN MORE COMMON.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO PROTECT
HOMEOWNERS -- IN MOBILE HOME
PARKS AND ALLOW THEM TO REBUILD
THEIR LIVES IF THE PARK
MANAGEMENT CHOOSES TO REBUILD.
THIRD THIS BILL PROVIDES A CLEAR
FRAMEWORK FOR WHAT PARK
MANAGEMENT.
SHALL CONSIDER WHEN APPROVING OR
TONIGHT PROSPECTIVE PURCHASER
WHAT THE PROSPECTIVE PURCHASERS
CAN PROVIDE THE PARK MANAGEMENT.
THE GOALS OF THESE CHANGES ARE
HELP AUDIBLE CALIFORNIANS
BECAUSE OF AGE DISABILITY INCOME
OR SOME COMBINATION THEREOF --
FOR WHOM THESE MOBILE HOMES ARE
ONE OF THE LAST VESTIGES OF
AFFORDABLE OUT HOUSING WOULD BE
HERE TODAY TESTIFIED SUPPORTERS
PER STAND CORPORATE COUNSEL FOR
THE GOLD STATE MANUFACTURED HOME
HONESTLY.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M HAPPY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
REQUEST DRIVE VOTE ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
IN ADDITION TO CLARIFYING THE
SECTION ONE ISSUES THAT THE
SENATOR JUST -- CAPABLE REFER --
TO SECTION TO THE BILL IS VERY
CRITICAL FOR OUR HOMEOWNER
CONSTITUENTS BECAUSE WHERE A
PARK IS DESTROYED BY FIRE IN THE
RESIDENTS ARE BURNED OUT.
THIS WOULD GIVE THEM -- A CHANCE.
TO SORT OF REBUILD THEIR OWN
LIVES AS THE PARK OWNER IS DOING
AND DOING THAT ON SUBSTANTIALLY
THE SAME RENTAL TERMS TO START
THE TENDENCY I THINK IS
IMPORTANT.
SO THAT THEY HAVE THE SAME
CHANCE THAT THE PARK OWNER HAS --
AND THERE ARE WAYS THAT THE PARK
COULD OBVIOUSLY -- RAISE RENTS
IF THEY NEEDED TO ONCE THE
INITIAL TENNESSEE AND SECTION
OCCURS I THINK THE AMENDMENTS TO
THE BILL HAVE NOW CAPABILITY --
PROVIDED FOR THE ISSUES OF
INCREASED COSTS FOR THE PARK
OWNERS.
THE THIRD SECTION IS REALLY
CRITICAL FOR ME I'VE ALWAYS
CALLED THIS THE BLACK HOLE OF
THE MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY LAW --
BECAUSE THIS SECTION TALKS ABOUT
THE STANDARDS THE PARK OWNERS TO
USE WHEN QUALIFYING PERSPECTIVE
PURCHASERS AND IT REFERS TO THE
FINANCIAL ABILITY TO PAY THE
RENT OR CHARGES OF THE PARK.
BUT THAT PHRASE HAS NEVER BEEN
ADEQUATELY DEFINED.
AND SO WHAT YOU'VE HAD IN THE
INDUSTRY IN MY THIRTY FIVE YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE IS THIS INCOME
TEST THIS THREE TO ONE INCOME
RATIO TEST.
THAT A PARK OWNER WILL USE
WITHOUT REALLY CONSIDERING ANY
OTHER ASSETS -- MANY TIMES OF
THE PROSPECTIVE PURCHASER.
WHICH IS.
OBVIOUSLY NOT THE WAY IT WOULD
WORK IF SOMEBODY WAS APPLYING
FOR A FOR A LOAN FOR EXAMPLE.
SO ADDING THOSE SPECIFIC OTHER
ASSET ISSUES THAT THE PARKER
NEEDS TO LOOK AT IS REALLY
CRITICAL -- ESPECIALLY IN SENIOR
PARKS WHERE YOU HAVE MORE
LIMITED -- CAPABILITY TO
PURCHASE AND WE KNOW THAT.
THE NUMBER OF MOBILE HOME
LENDERS IN THE IN THE INDUSTRY
IS DECREASING.
SO THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT A
PARK HONOR CANNOT REGION LEAD
HERE TO A SELF CREATED INCOME
RATIO ONLY THAT OTHER ASSETS
WILL NEED TO BE CONSIDERED -- I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND EXHORT
YOU -- TO JOIN ME AND CLOSING
THIS BLACK HOLE IN THE MALL PLAN
RESIDENCY Là THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING ROGER JOHNSON
REPRESENTING GEO SOME WHILE
GOLDEN STATE MOBILE HOMEOWNERS
LEAGUE.
WITH OVER SEVEN THOUSAND MEMBERS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TURN BLACK RISKY REGARDS -- IN
CITRUS HEIGHTS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
ELIZABETH FOR SANSKI RANCHER
YELLOW SENIOR MOM HOME COMMUNITY
AND DAVIS AND SENATOR DODD'S
DISTRICT AND WE ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I AM VILE FELLOWS FROM RANGE
CODER WILL.
AND CALIFORNIA AND I AM A MOBILE
HOME RESIDENT.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I'M JOE FELLOWS ELEVEN MOBILE
COUNTRY CLUB.
IN RANCHO CORDOVA IN SUPPORT.
I'M MARY VAN CLEEF.
AND SUPPORT THIS.
BILL.
ROBERT VAN CLEEF TO LIVE IN A
MOBILE HOME IN RANCHO CORDOVA.
AND PRESIDENT OF THE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
MICHELLE MONNING I IN THE MOBILE
HOME RESIDENT AND THE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION PRESIDENT AT A PARK
IN ROSEVILLE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING TONY WALLIS I'M A
MOBILE HOME RESIDENT IN A PARK
SENIOR PARK IN CITRUS HEIGHTS.
AS PRESIDENT OF THE HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION I REPRESENT THE PARK
WITH TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
SPACES AND WE ARE ALL IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KIANA VALENTINE ON
BEHALF OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
HIS OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
UNDER GOVERNOR ON BEHALF THE
WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION -- WE'RE
HERE TODAY TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION WE ACTUALLY WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US IN ACTUALLY
BRINGING ALL PARTIES TOGETHER --
FOR COMPROMISE AND WANT TO THINK
CENTER DOT AND HIS STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US.
ON BEHALF OF WMA AND THE
PARADISE HOME.
MOBILE HOME PARK OWNERS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND LOOK
FORWARD -- TO THE ACTUAL
LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
JEFF RESPECT ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL IN PRINT -- WE WERE MADE
AWARE OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE COMING THROUGH AND WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR AS WELL
AS CHAIR AND HIS STAFF FOR ALL
OF THEIR WORK -- ON THOSE
MOMENTS.
THOSE LIKELY TO SATISFY OUR
CONCERNS HOWEVER WE CANNOT
FORMALLY REMOVE OPPOSITION UNTIL
WE SEE WHAT THOSE LIMITS ARE AND
WHEN THEY'RE PRINT THANK YOU.
HI I'M KATHY KATANA I OWN
FORSKOLIN MOBILE HOME PARK IN
PARADISE WERE WHAT'S LEFT OF IT.
AND I JUST WANTED TO THANK
SENATOR DODD -- FOR THE MEASURED
RESPONSE HE BROUGHT TO OUR
CONCERNS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING FORWARD WITH OUR REBUILD
AND HAVING AS MANY RESIDENTS
COME BACK.
AS WHO'D LIKE TO JOIN US THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JASON OCCURRED WITH
THAT'LL STEEN GILBERT ROBESON
SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ALLIANCE JUST WANT TO
BRIEFLY ECHO THE COMMENTS OF W.
MAIN THE SENATOR EXPRESSING
APPRECIATION FOR YOU AND YOUR
STAFF WORKING OF COURSE THE
SENATOR AND HIS STAFF.
WORK WE'RE VERY GLAD THAT WE'RE
IN A GOOD SPOT ON THIS BILL AND
WE ANTICIPATE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION WHAT'S THE SCENE THE
AMENDMENTS AND PRESS THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC ON
THIS ITEM BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING ON THESE TOUGH ISSUES --
FOR ACCEPTING THE MOMENTS AND
ALSO -- FOR WORKING TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE OPPOSITION --
THIS BILL WILL HELP TO CREATE A
PATH TO REBUILD MOBILE PARKS
AFTER MOBILE HOME PARKS AFTER
WILD FIRES.
AND OTHER DISASTERS THAT WORK
BOTH FOR PARK OWNERS AND
HOMEOWNERS AND ALSO APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT THERE WILL
HOPEFULLY BE A FAIRER AND MORE
TRANSPARENT PROCESS FOR SELLING
MOBILE HOMES AS WELL.
WITH THAT YOU HAVE MY SUPPORT
ANY OTHER COMMENTS MR GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- THANK
YOU CENTER FOR THE BILL I JUST --
LOOKING OVER IT -- A LOT OF THIS
ROOM MAKES SENSE TO ME AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON IT -- I
WAS JUST CURIOUS HOW YOU CAME UP
WITH.
WITH THE NOTION OF OF THREE
COMPANIONS DURING A CALENDAR
YEAR I WASN'T HERE OBVIOUSLY
WHEN YOU -- PASSED -- I GUESS SB
ONE FORTY SEVEN ADDITIONALLY BUT
JUST CURSED HERE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOUR THINKING BEHIND THAT.
DO YOU WANT.
TO IT IS ESSENTIALLY WHAT WAS
WHAT WAS HAPPENING IS IS.
YOUR WILL WE DON'T HAVE VERY
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
FORMAL HOUSING SO IN MOBILE
HOMES OFTEN THERE'S YELLOW. TO
TWO ROOMS AND SOMETIMES THREE
ROOMS.
ADD -- YOU KNOW THE IDEA WAS IS.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
SENIORS AT THE END OF THEIR LIFE.
LIFESPAN WOULD THEY WANT
COMPANIONSHIP THAT'S ONE THEY
HAVE FRIENDS -- THAT -- PERHAPS --
YELLED CAN'T AFFORD THE RENT
ANYMORE WHERE THEY ARE SO IT
JUST SEEMED LIKE A A NATURAL
THAT THAT -- YEAH WOULD BE DONE
AND THAT WAS IT THE ESSENCE OF
THE BILL AND THEN THERE WAS SOME
CONFUSION IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
HOW THAT WAS THIS KIND OF A
CLEAN UP BILL.
I DON'T RELEASED SPECIFICALLY --
RECALL WHY THE NUMBER WAS --
THREE TO BE TOTALLY HONEST WITH
YOU I DON'T KNOW IF YOU DO I
THINK IT'S JUST THAT IT'S A
NUMBER THAT I THINK WOULD
REPRESENT A REASONABLE UPPER
LIMIT IN A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD.
WHERE COMPANIONS ARE CHANGED OUT
BY OTHER DEATH THEY'RE MOVING OR
ANY OTHER CIRCUMSTANCE ARE
OBVIOUS YOU SHOULD BE A LIMIT?
BUT BEFORE PARK OWNERS WERE
INTERPRETING IT IS SAYING YOU
CAN ONLY NAME WINE AND IF THAT
PERSON DIES OR LEAVES YOU CANNOT
FILL THAT VACANCY UNTIL THE
ENTIRE CALENDAR YEAR.
ELAPSES.
SO SO THE THE THE OTHER THING
YOU WOULD WANT TO HAVE A LOT
MORE THAN THAT BECAUSE THAT IT'S
MORE OF A TRANSIT HOUSING OR YOU
KNOW SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO.
I I I I I APPRECIATE -- YOU
BRING UP THE POINT THAT WAS
EXACTLY IT.
SO THIS IS THIS IS.
NOT THREE PERSONS AT ONE TIME
IT'S NOT LET'S JUST SAY THAT
SOMEBODY YOU HAD A SENIOR SAYS
THAT MOVED IN WITH SOMEBODY.
THAT PERSON DIED.
OR THAT PERSON HAD TO MOVE AND
MOVE INTO A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY OR MOVE IN WITH A
FAMILY MEMBER SO NOW THIS ROOM
IS OPEN AGAIN.
IT'S SO THAT THAT WOULD BE THE
SAY THAT HAPPENS OF THREE MONTHS
THAT WOULD BE NUMBER SOMEBODY
ELSE CAME IN THERE THAT'S NUMBER.
TWO SIX MONTHS LATER IT HAPPENS
AGAIN -- THAT WOULD BE THE TH
THE THIRD AND FINAL.
ONE OKAY I I APPRECIATE THAT I
MEAN I IF I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THAT I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO I JUST --
YOU KNOW THE ON SOME OF THESE
ISSUES I THINK A LIGHTER TOUCH
APPROACH FROM SACRAMENTO MIGHT
BE THE BETTER WAY TO GO AND
LETTING FOLKS ON THE GROUND WORK
OUT SOME OF THESE DETAILS AMONG
THEMSELVES -- SO APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO -- AND
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
AND I THINK MOST OF THE TIME.
I THINK MOST THE TIME YOU'RE
RIGHT.
WHAT WHAT HAPPENS IS IS OFTEN
LAWS ARE ARE MADE BECAUSE IN
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES?
YOU DON'T HAVE -- VOTERS FOR
EXAMPLE THAT ARE FLEXIBLE I
APPRECIATE THAT PARK OWNERS THAT
ARE HERE THAT ARE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL -- OFTENTIMES IT'S
IT'S THE GOOD ONES THAT -- YOU
KNOW HAVE HAVE TO HAVE ISSUES
LIKE THIS WITH YEAH WOOD WITH
BILLS BY PER SHARE COMMENTS.
ANALYSTS ARE ANY FINAL COMMENTS
SENATOR ANY FINAL WORDS I FASTER
AYE.
IS OUR MOTION FOR THIS.
IS OUR SECOND [inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY [inaudible]
YEAH.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO BUY
CHIU I DEEP HI I GABRIEL GABRIEL
I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY I LEE MON MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
YOUR BILLS OUT.
WAY FRED ON MEMBERS.
INVITE SENATOR JACKSON UP FOR
FOR ITEM FILE ITEM TO SP.
ONE EIGHTY TWO BEFORE SHE
PRESENTS I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR A
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT COUNTER
RIGHT SEE THAT WE HAVE TWO ITEMS
FROM CENTER JACKSON AS WELL AS
AN EFFECTS ARE WILK A MOTION AND
A SECOND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS ARE TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU HI CHIU I HI
I GABRIEL.
GIVE ME A LIFE LORIA GLORIA AYE
KILEY.
KILEY IDLY MON MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE QUIRK SILVA.
THE CONSENT AGENDA IS PASSABLE
WAIT FOR ADAM MEMBERS -- GOING
OUT OF FILE ITEM. TO SB ONE
EIGHTY TWO IT'S OUR SECOND ITEM
TODAY ON WILDFIRES CENTER.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- THIS IS SB ONE EIGHTY
TWO IT IS A BILL.
THAT WILL REDUCE THE RISK OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE DAMAGE TO
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES.
BY STRENGTHENING LOCAL PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS IN VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD AREAS.
AND BY DIRECTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO DEVELOP
COMPREHENSIVE RETROFIT
STRATEGIES FOR STRUCTURES IN
COMMUNITIES IN NEED OF FIRE
HARDENING [inaudible]
SHE'S ME.
BUT BEFORE I CONTINUE I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE WITH THIS BILL AND
PARTICULARLY ON PROVISIONS
RELATING TO THE HOUSING
ALLOCATION -- I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO ACCEPT IS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
THOSE SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE.
AND WOULD LIKE TO COMMEND THE
CHAIR AND HIS STAFF FOR HELPING
STRIKE A WORKABLE BALANCE.
BETWEEN THE NEED TO REVIEW SOME
APPROVALS IN VERY HIGH FIRE
AREAS.
WITH THE NEED TO MEET REGIONAL
HOUSING TARGETS AND I AM
CONFIDENT THE SOLUTION WE FOUND
PROVIDES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
APPROPRIATE FLEXIBILITY.
WHILE ENSURING REGIONAL GOALS
ARE STILL MET.
WE HAVE BEEN ADDRESSING THE FIRE
ISSUE FROM A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS.
THE ONE THAT.
HASN'T BEEN AS ROBUST.
DEALS WITH BUILDING IN THE WILL
WAY.
THE WILDLIFE WILDLAND URBAN.
INTERFACE THE WILL WE IS AN AREA
WHERE MANY OF US LIVE -- IN
MYSELF INCLUDED AND IT IS OF
PARTICULAR CONCERN IN AREAS
WHERE WE BELIEVE THAT.
LIFE IS PERFECT AND WE DON'T
HAVE TO CONCERN OURSELVES WITH
THE PROBLEMS OF URBAN LIFE.
BUT THERE ARE CONCERNS THAT
REACH US ALL WHEN IT COMES TO
BUILDING IN PLACES WHERE MOTHER
NATURE.
DOES NOT NECESSARILY WANT US TO
BE.
SO.
CALIFORNIA'S PERSISTENT THREAD
OF WHILE FAR OF COURSE POSES A
SIGNIFICANT RISK TO HOMES AND
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND WHILE MUCH IS BEING DONE TO
BETTER MANAGE OUR FORESTS.
OF MORE HAS TO BE DONE TO HARDEN
EXISTING HOMES AND NEIGHBORHOODS
TO MAKE THEM MORE RESISTANT TO
WILDFIRE.
AND IMPROVE LAND USE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE DECISIONS TO
MINIMIZE WILDFIRE THREATS AT THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL.
AT A MARCH THIRTEENTH HEARING
FOCUSED ON DEVELOPMENT IN FIRE
PRONE REGIONS THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEES.
RECOMMENDED THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER ACTION TO BOLSTER LOCAL
PLANNING EFFORTS TO DESIGN MORE
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES. TO
CONDITION DEVELOPMENT APPROVALS
TO ENSURE THAT STRUCTURES AND
COMMUNITIES ARE ADEQUATELY
PROTECTED FROM FIRE.
AND TO ENCOURAGE DEVELOPMENT OUT
OF HARM'S WAY.
THAT IS A CHALLENGE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE BEAUTIFUL OCEANS WE HAVE
BEAUTIFUL MOUNTAINS AND
BEAUTIFUL HILLS AND PEOPLE WANT
TO LIVE THERE.
BUT THIS BILL AIMS TO DO EXACTLY
WHAT WAS ASKED IN THESE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND THAT IS
TO BE MINDFUL AND THOUGHTFUL
WHERE WE DEVELOP [inaudible]
NOW CONDITIONS.
OF UNDER THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY.
ONE EIGHTY TWO CONDITIONS NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND IDENTIFIED WILL
WE AREAS UPON CITIES AND
COUNTIES MEETING INTO A ROOM.
AND LATER PERMANENT WILDFIRE
RISK REDUCTION STANDARDS
INCLUDING FOR FIRE RESPONSE
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE AND
IGNITION REDUCTION.
IT ALSO REQUIRES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO VERIFY ONGOING
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FENCIBLE
SPACE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND
LOCAL FIRE PLANS AND WHILE FIRE
HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS WHEN APPLICABLE.
IT DIRECTS LOCALS TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE RETROFIT STRATEGY
FOR STRUCTURES ALREADY
VULNERABLE TO WILDFIRE.
INCLUDING PROCESSES FOR
IDENTIFYING IMPACTED
INFRASTRUCTURE GOALS AND
MILESTONES FOR COMPLETING
RETROFIT WORK AND IDENTIFYING
POTENTIAL FUNDING SOURCES AND
FINANCING STRATEGIES.
AND THE BILL DIRECTS THE OFFICE
OF STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO
UNDERTAKE A NOTICE AND COMMENT
RULE MAKING THAT ESTABLISHES.
A STATEWIDE WILDFIRE RISK
REDUCTION STANDARD TO ACCOUNT --
FOR CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE WEATHER
TYPOGRAPHY AND DEVELOPMENT
PATTERNS IN A MORE PRECISE AND
REGIONAL WAY.
I'M A CHANGES WE KNOW IS
CREATING THE POTENTIAL FOR
LONGER AND MORE SEVERE WILDFIRES
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND MANY IN THIS ROOM HAVE
PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED THOSE
FIRES -- WHETHER IT WAS.
IN SAN DIEGO A FEW YEARS AGO
WHETHER IT'S UP IN THE NORTHERN
PART OF THE STATE.
IN THE CENTRAL COAST WERE WE
EXPERIENCE THE THOMAS FIRES THAT
STARTED IN DECEMBER IS
OSTENSIBLY DURING THE POST FIRE
SEASON.
THESE ARE REAL THESE ARE
DANGEROUS THESE ARE ONGOING AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO SUFFER FROM
THEM IN THE FUTURE.
BUT WE NEED TO DO MORE TO
MITIGATE WE NEED TO DO MORE TO
BE PRO ACTIVE.
WHEN IT COMES TO IDENTIFYING STE
THE SAFEST PLACES TO DEVELOP
PARDON THOSE INFRASTRUCTURES
THAT ARE ALREADY IN THE FIRE
DANGER ZONES?
AND DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SAVE
LIVES PROTECT PROPERTY IN
COMMUNITY AND MEANINGFULLY
REDUCE FUTURE LIABILITY AND WITH
THAT I HAVE WITH ME TODAY TRACY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ERIC PHILLIPS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
pTRACY WRI WROTE COUNTY
REPRESENTS A CALIFORNIA -- THE
AUTHORED DID AN EXCELLENT JOB IN
OUTLINING WHAT THIS BILL DOES
AND SO -- FOR THE SAKE OF
BREVITY I WILL JUST SAY THAT --
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
WORKING WITH US -- TO GET THE
BILL IN A PLACE WITH THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEED ALLOCATION
HE'S AND REALLY FINDING THAT
BALANCE BETWEEN MAKING SURE THAT
ARE AT THE COMMUNITIES MOVING
FORWARD.
ARE SAFE BUT NOT IN ANY WAY
EXACERBATING ON THE HOUSING
CRISIS -- THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
THINGS IN HERE THAT -- THE ROLE
COUNTIES I THINK ON THE NATURAL
WOULD BE CONCERNED WITH HOWEVER
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE AUTHOR
HAS REALLY KIND OF FOUND THAT
BALANCE.
IN MAKING SURE THAT -- THAT WAY
THAT WE HAVE TIME AS LOCAL
COMMUNITIES -- TO TO GET THE
RESOURCES TO PUT ALL THE THE
PLANNING PIECES IN ORDER -- WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MOVING FORWARD
THOUGH SOME SORT OF LOCAL
PLANNING DOLLARS -- BECAUSE OF
THE THE EXTENSIVE -- PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE IN THE
BILL -- ALSO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING FORWARD IN WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S ERIC PHILLIPS AND THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION.
AND WE ALSO ARE HERE TO SUPPORT --
SB ONE EIGHTY TWO THIS MORNING --
WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF MEASURES
THAT REDUCE THE RISK OF
IDENTIFIED -- WILD FIRE HAZARD
I'M HOWEVER WE'RE ALSO I AM IN
FAVOR OF THE CAREFUL INFERRED
INTRODUCTION OF NEW DEVELOPMENT
WHERE IT IS APPROPRIATE TO DO SO
AND PART OF THE REASON THAT WE
SUPPORT SB ONE EIGHTY TWO IS
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IT STRIKES
THE RIGHT BALANCE.
BETWEEN THOSE NEEDS --
PARTICULARLY WITH THE EFFORTS
AND THAT THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE AUTHOR WERE ABLE
TO MAKE WITH THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED HERE TODAY --
WE THINK THAT THE BALANCE AND
ONE EIGHTY TWO BETWEEN.
HAVING ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS --
AND NEW DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS
WHILE ALLOWING DEVELOPMENT WHERE
APPROPRIATE IS -- THE RIGHT WAY
TO GO ABOUT -- REDUCING
UNNECESSARY RISK WITHOUT END DO
YOU SING UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
AS THAT WOULD UNDERMINE
STATEWIDE AND REGIONAL HOUSING
PRODUCTION GOALS BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT IS.
OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE -- IT'S
IMPORTANT WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT -- ARE PROPOSED TODAY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE WHAT --
ONE EIGHTY TWO WOULD WOULD AND
WOULD NOT DO IT WOULD NOT CHANGE
THE REGIONAL HOUSINGALLOCATION --
SO EVERY REGION WOOD RIDGE
RETAIN ITS OBLIGATION TO FULFILL
ITS SHARE OF THE STATE'S HOUSING
NEED -- HOWEVER IN INDIVIDUAL
JURISDICTIONS WITHIN THOSE
REGIONS -- WILD FIRE RISK WOULD
BE INCORPORATED INTO THE FACTORS
THAT GO INTO A SIGNING THE RENO
TO THOSE INDIVIDUAL
JURISDICTIONS AND THE BILL IS
PROPOSED TO INCLUDE.
FACTORS THAT WE FEEL ARE
SPECIFIC ENOUGH TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO PLANNERS -- WHILE
PREVENTING POTENTIAL ABUSES AND
UNWARRANTED REDUCTIONS IN RENO --
WHERE THEY THEY ARE NOT ACTUALLY
NECESSARY TO PROTECT AGAINST --
UNREASONABLE RISK OF WILD FIRE --
DAMAGE AND LOSS OF LIFE --
UNFORTUNATELY IT ALSO ALLOWS
REGIONAL EXPERTS TO CONTINUE TO
MAKE DETERMINATIONS ABOUT SAFETY --
IT HAS BOTH FORWARD AND BACKWARD
LOOKING METRICS AND WE ARE HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND
ASK THAT YOU DO THE SAME.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
CHAIR MEMBERS REBEKAH LEE ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON AS ELECTRIC UTILITY WE
HAVE TO DEPLOY THE ESSENTIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE REGARDLESS
WHETHER THE HOUSING IS BUILT AND
HI FIRE WRIST AREA ON OR NOT.
SO WE SEE SB ONE EIGHTY TWO AS A
CRITICAL PIECE OF THE
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION THAT'S
NEEDED TO ADDRESS STATE WHY
WILDFIRE REST OF CUSTOMERS.
AND THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE
THANK YOU AND ARTS AND I BOTH.
CARE MUNCE IN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES CONCUR WITH -- THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THE RURAL COUNTIES PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
THE MORNING CAMINO BEHALF SAVE
THE REDWOODS LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
PAUL MESA PACIFIC FOR STRESSED
ACTUALLY AS PART OF AMENDED
POSITION VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT
OFALL OF THE PROVISIONS RELATED
TO HOUSING AND RUNNING
APPRECIATE THE WORK ABOUT THE
SENATOR.
AND RC RC THERE ARE PROVISIONS
IN THE BILL THAT LOOK TO FIND
SOME -- SAFETY IN PREPAREDNESS
ACTIVITIES FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND ALLOCATIONS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY FOR FOR US
ALL FIRE PREVENTION WE THINK WE
NEED TO FIND ANOTHER.
WAY TO FUND THOSE IMPORTANT
ACTIVITIES RATHER THAN GOING
BACK TO THE WELL FOR THOSE FUNDS
THEY'RE ALREADY REALLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED FOR THOSE CURRENT
SAFETY -- NEEDS BUT ARMSTRONG'S
PORTABLE OTHERWISE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL OR ANY
TWO WINNERS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SILVIO FOR OUR
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND WHAT WE
DO HAVE OPPOSE POSITION WE WOULD
ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND MOVE A FOR
TODAY.
YOU KNOW OUR ISSUES HAVE BEEN
KIND OF TWO THINGS A LAND USE
BUCKET OF ISSUES AND A CODES AND
STANDARDS A BUCKET OF ISSUES.
LAND USE ISSUES WERE DEALT WITH
IN A EXTENT OF MAY TWENTY FOURTH
AMENDMENTS AND WE THINK BASED ON
THE VERY VERY COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS THAT'S BEING LED BY
SENATOR JACKSON ON THIS ISSUE
THAT WE'RE GONNA GET THERE ON
OUR REMAINING ISSUE SO -- WE'VE
GOT A POSITION BUT I THINK IT'S
CLEAR WHAT WE THINK YOU SHOULD
DO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC ONE EXPRESS A
PERSPECTIVE ON THE BILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION.
I JUST WANT TO SAY SENATOR THANK
YOU FIRST FOR TACK LANE -- VERY
THORNY TOPIC THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT WHICH IS -- HOW WE
THINK ABOUT HOUSING -- AND
WILDFIRES IN THAT INTERSECTION --
AS WE HAVE HEARD THIS BILL DOES
NOT PRECLUDE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
IN THESE AREAS BUT AND SHORES AT
THE RISK OF FIRE AND PROTECTING
LIFE -- FOR CONSIDERED VERY
SIGNIFICANTLY IN ANY FUTURE
DEVELOPMENT I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND YOUR STAFF FOR
ENGAGING WITH OUR OFFICE AND THE
MANY STAKEHOLDERS VERTICALLY
AROUND -- THE AMENDMENTS
REGARDING RINA AND HELPING TO
FOCUS THE QUESTION ON WHETHER OR
NOT THAT PROCESS WOULD TRULY PUT
PEOPLE IN HARM'S WAY.
APPRECIATE THAT -- THE
DISCUSSION WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS WERE NOT LOSING THE
FOREST FOR THE TREES THIS IS A
GOOD BILL THROUGH A TOUGH TOPIC
AND WITH THAT I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT IT WITH THE MEMBERS THAT
WE'RE TAKING.
UNLESS THERE'S ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION.
OKAY THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND -- MADAM SECRETARY IN
LESS CENTER DO YOU HAVE ANY
CLOSING REMARKS SHAPE THE
DISCUSSION THIS IS -- THESE ARE
VERY TOUGH ISSUES THERE WHEN I
FIRST GOT ELECTED THAT THIS
WASN'T QUITE WHAT I EXPECTED I'D
BE ADDRESSING BUT WHEN YOU'VE
BEEN THROUGH SO MANY WILDFIRES
IN AS WE SEE THE STATE BURNING
UP REGULARLY.
THIS BECOMES A CRITICAL
DISCUSSION AND I APPRECIATE ALL
THE HARD WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WE WILL -- TAKE A VOTE
I'LL JUST NOTE THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE.
BOB MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHIU
HI CHIU I TAPE.
GABRIELLE.
GABBY ALLY GLORIA GLORIA AYE
KILEY.
KILEY IDLY MON.
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT
QUIRK SILVA.
YOUR MEASURES OUT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SENATOR AND AT THIS TIME WE
WILL WAIT FOR OTHER SENATE
AUTHORS.
YES WE CAN ADD ON WE HAVE TAKEN
PROBABLY FIVE OR SIX ITEMS AT
THIS POINT FILE LET ITEM A ONE
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
GABRIELLE.
FILE ITEM WELL IN ONE FELL.
GABRIEL I LEE MON.
THE MONTH HI MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIN CHINA.
JUST TO FOLLOW HIM TO FOLLOW HIM
FOR SB TWO SEVENTY FOUR DODD.
LEON REVERSE.
LIMóN FILE ITEM FOR FOR THE
MONTH I QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI.
FILE ITEM SIX SB TWO EIGHTY TWO
BELL [inaudible]
GABRIELLE.
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI.
IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM ELEVEN SB
SIX SEVENTY TO HELP.
GABRIELLE.
GABRIEL I GLORIA GLORIA I KILEY
KILEY AYE LEE MON.
WE MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NINE QUIRK SILVA.
HI.
AND GOING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THE MISSING NUMBERS.
THE MONTH.
THE MONTH I QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
WITH THAT I THINK WE STILL OF
SIX CENTER AUTHORS LEFT SO.
WE WILL WAIT FOR THEM
.
WELCOME FILE ITEM THIRTEEN SB
SEVEN FORTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESENT
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
H..
IT IS NOW.
SORRY ABOUT THAT I HAVE A PRETTY
LOUD VOICE BUT I COULD NOT HEAR
IT.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS -- I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY THINKING THIS
COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL AND APPRECIATE
THE THOUGHTFUL CUT CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'VE WE'VE HAD I'M HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE MOMENTS.
NUMBER ONE INTO LISTED ON PAGES
FIVE AND SIX OF THE ANALYSIS
WHICH ARE LARGER THE TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING IN NATURE AND
ENHANCE THE BILL SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT I JUST WANNA
MAKE IT CLEAR FOR COLLEAGUES --
THE CENTER I'VE DISCUSSED MEMON
OR THREE AND WE'RE FINE WITH NOT
ASK YOU TO TAKE THAT SO.
THANK YOU I JUST MAKE SURE
THAT'S CLEAR THANK YOU.
AS WE ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA FACES
THE DUAL CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS
AND THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITH THE RESULTING
BURDEN FALLING PARTICULARLY HARD.
ON PEOPLE LIVING WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS NEARLY A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE
HOMELESS IN CALIFORNIA ON ANY
GIVEN NIGHT AND ABOUT A THIRD OF
THOSE ARE ESTIMATED TO BE LIVING
WITH A MALE MENTAL ILLNESS.
IN MONTEREY COUNTY ARE BY ANY
ACCOUNT FOUND HOMELESSNESS HAD
GREW 23% BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN
AND 201-720-00800 THIRTY SEVEN
INDIVIDUALS THE HIGHEST LEVEL IN
TEN YEARS WE KNOW THAT HAVING
PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS HEALTH
CONDITIONS.
LIVING ON SHELTERED OR CYCLING
IN AND OUT OF HOSPITALS.
AND INCARCERATION IS COSTLY TO
THE PUBLIC AND RESULT IN THAT
NEEDLESS SUFFERING FOR THE
HOMELESS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT LAST FALL
CALIFORNIA VOTERS OVERWHELMINGLY
APPROVED PROPOSITION TWO WHICH
IS THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
INITIATIVE.
WHICH AUTHORIZES THE STATE TO
ISSUE TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
BONDS TO CREATE TWENTY THOUSAND
UNITS A PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR HOMELESS MENTALLY
ILL INDIVIDUALS.
RESEARCH SHOWS SUCH HOUSING
KEEPS PEOPLE INSIDE REDUCES
ILLNESS AND SUFFERING AND
ULTIMATELY LOWERS PUBLIC COSTS
SB SEVENTY SIX SEVEN FORTY FOUR
HELPS FULFILL THE INTENT OF THE
VOTERS BY CLARIFYING AND
STREAMLINING THE LOCAL APPROVAL
PROCESS. FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING
AND ASSOCIATED SERVICES LIKE
THOSE AT NO PLACE LIKE HOME
BONDS ARE FINDING.
IT UTILIZES THE STREAMLINING
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING PROJECTSINVASION IN
LAST YEAR'S AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
TWO AND APPLIES THIS PROCESS TO
THE PROPOSITION TO SUPPORT OF
HOUSING IN ORDER TO EXPEDITE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING FOR
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
SUFFERING WITH THE MOUNT MENTAL
ILLNESSES.
THE BILL EXPANDS ADDITION
DEFINITION OF SUPPORT OF HOUSING
AND INCLUDES THAT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING MAY BE USED BY RIGHT
INTONES WERE MULTI FAMILY IN
MIXED USE ARE PERMITTED.
CALIFORNIA VOTERS MADE IT CLEAR
THAT THEY WANT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS AND ARE
HOMELESS TO BE SHELTERED AND
CARE.
FOR NO PLACE LIKE HOME GOT MORE
VOTES THAN ANY OTHER MEASURE ON
THE NOVEMBER BALLOT.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
SEVEN FORTY FOUR WITH ME TODAY
IS A GENERALIST WITH THIS TIME
BURKE INSTITUTE AND TINA
THOMPSON WITH THOMPSON Là GROUP
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
PLEASE.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS SOME
MAJOR ON ADDRESS WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE AND WE ARE
VERY PROUD TO BE SPONSORING SB.
SEVEN FOUR FOUR AS WE HAVE HEARD
THE REPORTS TO TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN HOMELESS POINT AND TIME
COUNT REFLECTS AN INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS.
WHICH ONLY UNDERSCORES THE NEED
FOR SB SEVEN FOUR FOUR WHICH
REQUIRES A STREAMLINED EXPEDITED
REVIEW PROCESS FOR THESE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME HOUSING SPUR OF
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS.
THE MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
UNDER ON SHELTER THE HOMELESS
POPULATION IS CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS MEANING THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN HOMELESS FOR A YEAR OR MORE
OR HAVE EXPERIENCED AT LEAST
FOUR EPISODES OF HOMELESSNESS.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT ONE THIRD
OF CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS
POPULATION IS LIVING WITH A
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
WE KNOW THAT THE LONGER A PERSON
EXPERIENCES HOMELESSNESS THE
CHANCES OF DEVELOPING A SERIOUS
MENTAL DISORDER US OR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER.
INCREASES EXPONENTIALLY.
ETCETERA CABALLERO HAS ALREADY
SAID SB SEVEN FOUR FOUR WILL
HELP DELIVER THE VOTERS DESIRED
MANDATE TO BUILD THESE TWENTY
THOUSAND AS A PART OF HOUSING
UNITS IN CALIFORNIA.
SB SEVEN FOUR FOUR POINTS
HOMELESSNESS TOWARDS A PATHWAY
OF RECOVERY AND WELL BEING I AM
PROUD TO BE A JOINT BY -- TINA
THOMAS -- STEINBERG INSTITUTE
BOARD MEMBER AND ALSO A LEADING
ATTORNEY ON LAND USE POLICY IF
IT NEEDED.
YEAH I'M HERE TO STANDS OR
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS
OF THE BILL.
IT'S BEEN A MOTION AS OUR SECOND.
I'LL SECOND IT OTHER SUPPORTERS.
HI MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SYLVIA'S SILLY SHAUN BEHALF OF
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED THANK
YOU.
DEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
CENTER JUST ONE APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON THIS -- WE CERTAINLY --
SEE VERY SIMILARLY I'D I'D I ON
THE GOALS I KNOW THIS IS A BILL
THAT IN PART OF MEN'S A. B.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO WHICH I HAD
WRITTEN LAST YEAR WHICH THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED AND WITHIN
MOMENTS -- HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
CHANGES TO THAT BILL TO FINE
TUNE IT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
BUILDING.
THE HOUSING WE NEED TO ADDRESS
OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN SO WITH THAT
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT ANY FINAL
COMMENTS.
NO I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR FOR THE ASSISTANCE ON ON
THIS BILL -- THIS IS A COMPLETE
COMPANION TO A GREAT BILL THAT
YOU THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO GET
PASSED LAST YEAR AND SO I'M
REALLY HAPPY THAT WE WERE ABLE --
TO WORK IT OUT BUT FOR TO THIS
MOVING FORWARD.
WITH THAT THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN NATURAL RESOURCES TO HI
HI DAVE GABRIELLE.
GABBY ALLY GLORIA KILEY KILEY
IDLY MON.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I QUIRK
SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
YOU HAVE FIVE WHAT'S YOUR BILLS
OUT WILL WAIT FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
CENTER.
CENTER MORE LOCK.
I JUST WANNA A STATE ON THE
RECORD THE MEMBERS FOR THIS BILL
WILL BE TAKEN IN NATURAL
RESOURCES SO.
WITH THAT WE WILL NOW GO TO FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN SB SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR MORLOCK SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
VICE CHAIR SB.
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR ATTEMPTS TO
RESOLVE ONE SIMPLE CONUNDRUM
WHAT IF YOU HAD ELECTION. FOR
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION AND
ANOTHER AND NOT ENOUGH
CANDIDATES FILED TO RUN.
IF THERE IS NO DOUBLE SLATE DO
YOU STILL GO THROUGH THE EXPENSE
OF MAILING.
OUT BALLOTS WHEN THE OUTCOME
WILL BE THE SAME.
IT WOULD BE EASIER AND LESS
COSTLY TO RULE THAT THE SLATE
ONE BY ACCLAMATION.
COLLEAGUES I HAVE THREE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS IN A
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY THAT
SPENDING TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER ELECTION FOR THREE HOMERS
ASSOCIATIONS.
WITH TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED UNITS EACH YEAR.
SB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR WOULD ALLOW
AN UNCONTESTED SLATE TO WIN BY
ACCLAMATION AT THE END OF A
NOTICE FILING PERIOD THE SAVING
RETIREES.
IN LARGE SIX THOUSAND PLUS
COMMUNITIES SIGNIFICAN PRINTING
AND MAILING COSTS.
LET'S HOPE ALL HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION BOARD RACES HAVE
MORE CANDIDATES THAN OPENINGS
BUT WHEN THEY DON'T SB SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR WILL SAVE COSTS. FOR
LARGER ASSOCIATIONS AND I HAVE A
WITNESS HERE.
TOO ASSIST IN OUR PRESENTATION.
WARNING CHAIR MEMBERS -- MY
NAME'S JEFF PARKER ON THE CEO OF
LAGUNA WOODS VILLAGE AND ORANGE
COUNTY -- IT'S A COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT OF MORE THAN TWELVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED HOMES IN
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
WE ARE ONE OF THE ASSOCIATIONS
OF THE SENATOR -- GRACIOUSLY TO
HELP SPONSOR THIS BILL ON SB --
FIFTY FOUR WHAT WAS INDICATED
BEFORE IS THAT WE HAVE THREE
GOVERNING BOARDS -- THREE
DIFFERENT ASSOCIATIONS AND THIS
BEING ABLE TO VOTE BY
ACCLAMATION IS IMPORTANT TO US
AND TRYING.
TO BE AUSTERE IN OUR BUDGET
PROCESS WE HAVE -- RESIDENTS ARE
ON FIXED INCOMES AND WHENEVER
THEY SEE US SPENDING TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR AN ELECTION
WHICH WE ONLY HAVE THE SAME
AMOUNT OF THEIR KEEP CLAMOR WHY
HE'S BEEN IN TWENTY THOUSAND ON
NOW WHEN YOU COULD.
YOU KNOW PROVIDE US BETTER
SERVICES SO -- VERY SIMILAR TO I
WORKED ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT YOU
KNOW AS LOCAL GOVERNMENT SCHOOL
BOARDS HAVE ACCLAMATION IN THE
PROCESS AND UNDER.
GOVERNMENT CODE WE'RE LOOKING
FOR THE SAME KIND OF RELIEF --
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE THIS AS A
CHOICE IF AN H. AWAY DOESN'T
WANT TO DO THIS THEN THEY CAN GO
AHEAD AND SPEND THEIR MONEY --
BUT WE'RE TRYING TO BE APPROVAL
ABOUT OUR MONEY SPENT AND IF WE
DON'T HAVE CANDIDATES AND TRUST
ME WE GO OUT AND GONNA GET
STUMPED THE THE GROUNDS WERE
LOOKING FOR CANDIDATES BUT OFTEN
TIMES WE JUST CAN'T BECAUSE
WE'RE VERY BUSY H. AWAY.
THE RESPONSIBILITIES ARE GREAT
AND SO WE HOPE YOU SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
WELL I I GET TO ACT AS THE CHAIR
BECAUSE I'M THE SENIOR MEMBER
HERE WOW I LOVE THIS ALL RIGHT
SO MISTER MOORE LIKE TELL US ALL
THE REASON NO I'M JOKING -- DO
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SCENE NINE ARE THERE ANY.
OF OKAY.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION'S
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
ACTION COMMITTEE.
HOW WE RELUCTANTLY -- RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL -- WE
SUPPORT THE UNDERLYING PREMISE
OF THE BILL AND CENTER MORLOCK
IS EXACTLY RIGHT AND WE SUPPORT
A LAGUNA WOODS IN THEIR EFFORT
OF OF SEEKING ELECTION BY
ACCLAMATION THIS IS BEEN A HIGH
PRIORITY POLICY ISSUE FOR US FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS AND WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE.
NUMBER OF ASSOCIATIONS IN THE
STATE THAT FIND THEMSELVES IN
THIS EXACT SITUATION THEY HAVE
BOARD MEMBER ELECTIONS IN THE
NOT ENOUGH MA'AM MEMBERS.
NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE RUNNING TO
FILL THOSE SLOTS AND STILL
REQUIRED TO DO AN ELECTION THEY
ARE COSTLY PROCESS THESE THEY
ARE COMPREHENSIVE AND
COMPLICATED PROCESS SEES.
BUT FOR THE SAME REASONS WE
OPPOSED SB THREE TWENTY THREE IN
THIS LAST COMMITTEE HEARING WE
MUST OPPOSE THIS BILL -- IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT THE LANGUAGE
WAS FORCED TO BE ADDED TO THIS
BILL THAT WOULD STRIP AND
ASSOCIATIONS AUTHORITY LOCAL
AUTHORITY TO DEEM -- THE
REQUIREMENTS AND THE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR BOARD MEMBER --
AND IT'S BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT
THAT THAT LANGUAGE WILL HAVE ONE
ASSOCIATIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA I WE'RE REQUIRED TO
OPPOSE. TO OPPOSE THE BILL SO I
RELUCTANTLY I ASK FOR A NO VOTE
THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE WHO IS
IN OPPOSITION.
SAME NONE -- I'M GOING TO ASK
THE AUTHOR ARE YOU GOING TO TAKE
THAT AMENDMENTS CORRECT.
CORRECT ALRIGHT WITH THAT.
NO ONE ELSE SPEAKING A QUICK WE
GOT A MOTION AND A SECOND ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS ALL
RIGHT -- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
TAKE THE ROLE WHICH LIKE ME TO
CLOSE.
YES I WOULD LIKE THE OF VERY
HIGH WELL.
WE HAVE A LITTLE BANTERING GOING
BACK BECAUSE HE'S THE SOUTH
COUNTY GUY.
A PLEASURE TO BE.
BEFORE YOU MADAM CHAIR -- WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT COMMONSENSE HERE
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TRYING
TO GET A SIMPLE -- PROCEDURE
RESOLVED ONLY TO FIND YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE COMING IN THAT --
THAT'LL HELP ONE GROUP ABSENT
OTHER GROUP BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIND THE SWEET SPOT MANAGER BUT
FOR CRYING OUT LOUD SPENDING
SIXTY THOUSAND A YEAR. FOR A
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY -- WITH NO
CHANGE IN THE OUTCOME IT SEEMS
LIKE WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO STEP
UP AND GET THIS DONE SO I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
ARE YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND AND CALL THE ROLL.
A MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO A
TAPE GABRIELLE.
GABRIEL I GLORIA KILEY.
KILEY I ONLY MON.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
QUIRK SILVA HI FOLKS FEEL BY.
I THINK WE'LL KEEP ROLE OPEN
THANK YOU MANAGER ART THANK YOU
ALEX [inaudible]
AW.
YOU ARE UP SENATOR HERTZBERG TO
RESENT TO US SB.
TWO FIVE EIGHT GOES OFF AND TALK
ABOUT THIS.
WHEN I DURING HIS [inaudible]
THREE TWO FIFTY EIGHT YES.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE GOT A MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL'S SECOND HER AND A
SECOND.
OKAY.
I'LL MAKE IT FAST THANK YOU
BECAUSE I AM A TRAVELS AND STUFF --
HI EVERYBODY.
SO AS WE FEEL THE URGENCY OF THE
HOMELESS ISSUE THAT IN.
IMPACTS SO MANY COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE.
AND WE COME UP WITH ALL THESE
FANCY SH NANCY APPROACHES FOR
NEW HOUSING IN SHELTERS AND ALL
THE OTHER FANCY SHARANSKY STUFF
WE DO.
IS ONE SMALL FIX THAT IMPACTS
PEOPLE IN A VERY SIGNIFICANT WAY
AND THAT'S THEIR PETS.
SO MANY PEOPLE WHO FIND
THEMSELVES TO BE HOMELESS AND
LIVING ON THE STREETS ONLY FIND.
THEIR GREAT FRIEND IN THEIR PET.
AND THEY ARE NOT UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER ANY WEATHER
CONDITIONS.
GO WITHIN TO A SHELTER WITHOUT
THEIR MOST IMPORTANT LOVE.
ONE END OF ISSUE.
SO AS WE DEVELOP PUBLIC POLICY.
TO TRY TO GET PEOPLE OFF THE
STREET GIVEN SHELTER AND
SERVICES AND ALL THE OTHER
THINGS.
WE HAVE TO DO WITH THE CORE.
TAKE CARE OF THEIR PETS.
DID OF ISSUE.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT'S
ONLY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IT
SHOULD BE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
WHY BECAUSE IT'S THE CHEAPEST
MONEY WITH THE GREATEST IMPACT
FOR FOLKS AND FOR THEIR PETS?
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
THIS BILL THE GOVERNOR TALKS
ABOUT PETS IN IS HOUSING BILL
THAT WE PASSED THIRTY NINE ZERO
OFF THE SENATE FLOOR.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE IT SHORTLY WE
THINK IT'S PRETTY IMPORTANT
PRETTY SIMPLE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND WE HAVE A SUPPORTERS HERE
TO SPEAK YES GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M JENNIFER
APPEARING HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE BEST FRIENDS ANIMAL
SOCIETY TO SAN DIEGO HUMANE
SOCIETY AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
SPCA AND WE APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE. FOR
INCLUDING FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE RECENTLY ENACTED BUDGET.
TO ENSURE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS LOCAL
EFFORTS TO AID PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ALONG
WITH THEIR PETS THIS FUNDING IS
ALIGNED WITH A SLEDGE WITH THIS
BILL THE REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING COMMITTEE OF ELEMENT
TO DEVELOP AND ADMINISTER
PROGRAMS THAT AWARD GRANTS TO
QUALIFIED AGENCIES PROVIDING
HOUSING. FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ALONG WITH THEIR
PETS IN SAN DIEGO AT LEAST NINE
THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS EVERY NIGHT OF
THOSE NEARLY FIVE THOUSAND MEN
WOMEN AND CHILDREN LIE DOWN TO
SLEEP EACH NIGHT.
INSIDE ON SIDEWALKS IN DOORWAYS
CANYONS IN ALLEYS SOME CHOOSE TO
LIVE IN THEIR CAR FOR LACK OF
PET FRIENDLY OR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THOSE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
WITH PETS HAVE SAID REPEATEDLY
THAT THEIR COMPANION ANIMALS ARE
ALL THEY HAVE AND GIVE THEM A
PURPOSE AND REASON TO LIVE.
IN SAN FRANCISCO HOMELESSNESS IS
ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL ISSUES
WERE FACING HOW TO PROVIDE
VETERINARY CARE FOR THE PETS OF
THOSE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
IS A PROBLEM FOR MANY
ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS PROGRAM IN THE STATE
FUNDING WILL HELP MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON PROVIDE
LIFESAVING SERVICES TO THOSE WHO
MIGHT OTHERWISE GO WITHOUT.
AND FINALLY HERE IN THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO OUR FRONT ST SHELTER
INVESTED LOCAL GENERAL FUND
GRANTS AND FUND RAISING IN
PHARMACEUTICALS CRATES FOOD
LEASHES AND EVEN SOME BEHAVIOR
TRAINING FOR THE TRIAGE SHELTER
IN NORTH SACRAMENTO.
THE OBJECTIVE WAS TO BOTH CARE
FOR THE ANIMAL IN THE MOMENT AND
TO PREPARE THEM TO BE THE KINDS
OF COMPANION TO DO NOT POSE A
BARRIER TO OTHER HOUSING OPTIONS.
FOR EVER GOING TO SOLVE THIS
CRISIS WE MUST ADDRESS THE
ANIMAL COMPONENT I DR -- AND I
THINK SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR
LOOKING OUT FOR BOTH ENDS OF THE
LEASH [inaudible]
NEXT.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FIFTY EIGHT MY NAME IS ENTERED
HER THINK I'M A PROGRAM ANALYST
IN THE OFFICE UPON THE SERVICES
FOR THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO.
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO HAS BEEN
ENGAGED IN INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS
TO BRING SERVICES AND HOUSING TO
THOSE MOST IN NEED AND TO
ADDRESS THE COMMUNITY IMPACTS OF
ON SHELTER HOMELESSNESS.
WE RECENTLY OPERATED A LOW
BARRIER TRIAGE SHELTER THAT
ALLOWED INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND WHO WISH TO
REMAIN WITH THEIR PAT TO ACCESS
SHELTER AND ENGAGE IN SERVICES.
THIS APPROACH FOLLOWS A
NATIONWIDE BEST PRACTICE AND
PROVED SUCCESSFUL FOR THE CITY
AND MANY OF OUR ON HOME TO
RESIDENTS A GOOD NUMBER OF WHOM
ENTERED THE SHELTER AFTER
SEVERAL YEARS OF BEING
DISCONNECTED FROM OKLAHOMA
SERVICES.
IN IT SIXTEEN MONTHS OF
OPERATIONS THIS LOW BARRIER
SHELTER SERVE SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT INDIVIDUALS AND ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO PATS.
AT ANY GIVEN TIME NEARLY 25% OF
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS.
WERE SHELTERED WITH THEIR PETS
AND SUCCESSFULLY COHABITATING
WITH PARTICIPANTS WITHOUT PETS
DEMONSTRATING THAT IT IS
POSSIBLE TO OPERATE SUCH A
PROGRAM WE OFFERED ANIMAL
SERVICES LIKE MEDICAL CARE
LICENSING VACCINATIONS.
AND NEUTERING AND SPAIN SERVICES
TO PETS IN THE SHELTER BUT ALSO
SUPPORTED PET OWNERS IN MAKING
THE TRANSITION FROM LIVING ON
SHELTERED. TO LIVING IN A
CONGREGATE FACILITY.
THE SOFT SKILLS PROVED VALUABLE
AS MANY OF THESE ALL THE
PARTICIPANTS MOVED ON TO BEING
HOUSED WITH THEIR DOG OR CAT.
ANIMAL CARE SERVICES AT THE
SHELTER WERE PROVIDED BY THE
CITY SPONSORED ANIMAL SHELTER
WHICH ALSO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
PET OWNERS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OUT OF THEIR
HEADQUARTERS.
NEAR OLD SACRAMENTO.
AND THEIR STAFF CONTINUE TO SEE
THE EVERY DAY NEED FOR ANIMAL
CARE SERVICES FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES ON HOME RESIDENTS.
BY PROVIDING ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
PETS WERE ABLE TO ENGAGE PEOPLE
WHO OTHERWISE WERE NOT
CONNECTING TO WRAP AROUND
SERVICES INCLUDING RE HOUSING
FOCUSED SERVICES BECAUSE OF THE
SUCCESS OF THE CITY'S SHELTER
AND THE SUCCESS OF SIMILAR
PROGRAMS FUNDED BY OUR PARTNERS
AT THE COUNTY.
THE CITY CONTINUES TO PLAN FOR
ADDITIONAL SHELTERS WHICH WILL
ACCOMMODATE -- FOLKS WITH THEIR
PETS.
THE PROGRAM CREATED BY SB TWO
FIFTY EIGHT WITH EDUCATED
FUNDING COULD ALLOW THE CITY AND
OTHERS TO CONTINUE PROVIDING
CRITICAL SERVICES FOR PETS AND
HELP US BOTH GET PEOPLE AND PETS
OFF THE STREETS.
AND INTO HOUSING AND SERVICES
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU I WILL DRAG OUT MY
WONDERFUL LITTLE PERIOD HERE
JUST TO GET THIS -- SUPPORT AND
THEN HAND THE GAVEL OVER.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS PLEASE BE HERE IN
SUPPORT.
DEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF MARS
PET CARE AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING HERE MEMBERS THERE
DAHLE HIM BADLY CALIFORNIA
CITIES WERE NOT REFLECTING THE
ANALYSIS BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANKS VERY MUCH.
AND AGAIN WE HAVE OUR VICE CHAIR
HERE AND I REALLY LIKE THIS JOB
RIGHT NOW SO I THINK WE SHOULD
MAKE A MOTION THAT THE SENIOR
MEMBER GETS TO CHAIR ALL THE
COMMITTEES.
BUT OKAY WE WON'T ANY SECONDS.
AGO.
COMMITTEE GOT IT [inaudible]
OF ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THE MR
GABLE.
FIGURE -- THINK IT'S A REALLY
SMART IDEA ASKREDDIT IS CO
AUTHOR BEAUTIFUL THANK YOU.
THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY THAT'S JUST
AN ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEEDING AS
OPPOSED TO SEVEN INTO OUR ROLE
ISSUE -- ANY EIGHTY UP -- MISTER
QUIRK SILVA.
I'LL MAKE A FEW COMMENTS -- IT
WAS A QUICK PRESENTATION AND AS
READY JUST.
TO GO OF FROM THE MOTION.
TO A SECOND WHICH I AGREE WITH
BUT I DO HAVE TO MAKE COMMENTS
BECAUSE A FEW TIMES WERE REALLY
WILL RUSH WE SAY THINGS LIKE --
IT'S WHICH YOU'VE GOT SUPPORT
SUPPORT OR OF LET'S JUST MOVE
THROUGH THE BUT THIS IS A REALLY
POWERFUL BILL -- AND IT MEANS SO
MUCH. ONE OF THE THINGS IF YOU
HAVE ENGAGE WITH PEOPLE WHO.
ARE ACTUALLY EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND I AND I LIKE TO
SAY EXPERIENCING BECAUSE
HOPEFULLY IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
FOREVER.
BUT YOU WILL NOTE THAT EXACTLY
AS YOUR BILL SAYS THEY ARE MORE
WILLING TO DEFER HOUSING IN
ORDER TO STAY.
WITH THAT PAT AND IF YOU LOOK AT
IT EMOTIONALLY AND
PSYCHOLOGICALLY.
THEY HAVE AN ATTACHMENT AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY NEED.
I'VE RID OF RESEARCH QUITE A BIT
AND ONE OF THE PIECES OF DATA
SHOWED THE SUGGEST.
OF HOW MANY ACTUALLY MONTHS AND
EVEN YEARS A HOMELESS A PERSON
CAN GO WITHOUT HAVING ANY KIND
OF PHYSICAL TOUCH OR HUG FOR
SOMEBODY LOOKING AT THEM AND
ASKING THEM THEIR NAME OR AND SO
FORTH.
AND SO THEY DO GET VERY ATTACHED
ND THAT'S WHY NOT ONLY PETS
HAVE A MADE A DIFFERENCE FOR
THOSE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
ON OUR STREETS BUT ALSO IN OUR
PRISONS ALSO FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
AND HOSPITALS WE KNOW THAT IN
FOR ANY OF US WHO ARE A PET
OWNER WE KNOW.
WHAT A LOSSES WE HAD TO PUT OUR --
GOLDEN RETRIEVER DOWN JUST ABOUT
THIS TIME LAST YEAR AND IT IS A
HUGE LOSS.
BUT I WILL JUST SHOW IT WAS
CHAIR OR AND MY SHARING A
PERSONAL STORY WHICH IS SOME OF
YOU KNOW THAT MY BROTHER -- WHO
WAS EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS --
PASSED AWAY OR DIED -- IN
OCTOBER AND ONE THE LAST THINGS
THAT HE DID THAT HAD A BIG
IMPACT ON OUR FAMILY IS A HE WAS
OUT AT NIGHT AND SOMEBODY THREW
A LITTLE KITTEN OUT OF A CAR.
AND JUST KIND OF DISCARDED IT
WAS A RAINY NIGHT HE TOOK THE
KITTEN AND HE TOOK IT TO MY
MOTHER AND SAID THAT HE WANTED
HER TO KEEP IT.
AND EVEN THOUGH HE STILL HAD
MANY MOMENTS MOMENTSOF WITH HIS
CHRONIC ALCOHOLISM THE THING
THAT HE ASKED ABOUT EVERY TIME
HE SAW HER WAS HOW IS.
HOW IS THE KITTEN?
AND SO THAT'S JUST ONE LITTLE
STORY SO I SUPPORT THIS AND
WOULD LIKE TO BE A AUTHOR ON
THIS AS WELL GOOD THANK YOU.
YOU ARE STILL THE KITTEN.
SADLY SHE WAS TAKING THE KITTEN
TO SEE HIM AND THE KITTEN RAN
OUT.
JUMPED OUT OF THE BOX.
BUT WE FOUNDER ANOTHER KITTEN
ACTUALLY FROM SACRAMENTO -- OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAURA
FRIEDMAN HAD TO GET RID OF HER --
FOR CAT AND SHE HAS HIM NOW
HELLO.
CUT.
UP DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
HEARING NONE OF THAT ARE
HERTZBERG ARE YOU ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT.
LIKE THE GAY MEMBERS OF THE HAVE
NOTS YES I GUESS.
I DON'T TELL YOU DID BUT YOU
BETTER BETTER BE GOOD.
WITH THAT DO I DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FEC EMOTION WE DO
IN A SECOND OKAY IF -- IF
THERE'S AN ORDER COMMENTS -- THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS.
TO DEEP AYE AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEMOND [inaudible]
A MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I QUIRK SILVA QUIRK
SILVA HI [inaudible] FIVE OF
STATE HERBERT YOUR BILL WE SEE
FIVE BOTH WILL LEAVE THE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
ADD ON A GOOD AMENDMENTS I JUST
HEARD ABOUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I DON'T SEE THE THE ANY OTHER
AUTHORS MAYBE WE CAN DO THE THE
ADD ON FOR OTHER MEMBERS WHO MAY
HAVE MISSED FOLKS.
SIR I BELIEVE RIGHT NOW IS --
ONLY YOU -- AND I THINK IT WOULD.
YES WE HAVE DONE THAT -- WE HAVE --
TO ADD AND SB. ONE EIGHTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO WE IT'S IGHT NOW --
SEVEN TWO ZERO AND YOU ARE.
TO ADD ON WE JUST AS YOU ARE YOU
IN.
OR NOT VOTING NOT MORE NOT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB.
ONE EIGHT TWO IT'S A RIGHT NOW
SEVEN TWO ZERO WAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TAPE EDITING ON AND IT'S
NINE FORTY AND THEN WE HAVE OUR
ITEM NUMBER -- THIRTEEN FIVE TWO
ZERO WITH ONE ON BOARDING --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DATE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP I SOLD OVER
PLEASE [inaudible]
SIX THREE ZERO AND ITEM NUMBER --
FOURTEEN SEVEN FIFTY FOUR THIRDS
OF FOUR TWO ZERO AT THE MOMENT --
HOW WOULD CHOOSE?
HI.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DIP I OKAY WE WE
HAVE SEEN THE NECKS ARTHUR --
HERE WITH US SO -- WE WILL GO
NOW TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN CENTER RUBIO.
IT'S BEEN A A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
AND PLEASE MA'AM YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU JUST VERY BRIEFLY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN A BILL TO INCREASE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF HOMELESS
POLICIES.
BY INCLUDING VETERANS COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND PARENTS IN LIQUID
LIVED EXPERIENCE IN THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESS CRISIS THE COUNCIL
SERVES AS A STATEWIDE RESEARCH
ON AND IN HOMELESSNESS.
AD SO TODAY I HAVE SOMEONE HERE
WITH ME THAT WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
HIS EXPERIENCE OF THAT'S OKAY
[inaudible] EIGHT GOOD MORNING.
WHAT IS A HOMELESS PERSON LOOK
LIKE?
WHAT COMES TO YOUR MIND WHEN YOU
HEAR THE WORD HOMELESS?
I WAS HOMELESS FOR MOST OF THE
LAST SIX YEARS OFTEN AND
SHELTERED.
I SLEPT WHEREVER AND HOWEVER I
COULD I GET MY BELONGINGS IN A
SMALL STORAGE UNIT.
I WORKED OUT AND TOOK SHOWERS AT
THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR FITNESS ALL
SEVEN STREET.
IF YOU SAW ME ON THE STREETS
WHEN I WAS HOMELESS I LOOK.
JUST LIKE A LOOK TODAY.
BEFORE BECOMING HOMELESS I
SERVED AS AN INFANTRYMAN IN THE
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS IN
OPERATIONS ENDURING FREEDOM
IRAQI FREEDOM.
COSTA WILL FORCE AND MANY OTHERS.
I WENT UC DAVIS ON FULL MERIT
SCHOLARSHIP.
I HAD WELL PAYING JOBS AND
FINANCE AND I VOLUNTEERED MY
COMMUNITIES.
I HAVE TWO SONS THAT I'M VERY
PROUD OF MY OLDEST WALTERS FIVE
IN GOING INTO KINDERGARTEN
SACRAMENTO COUNTRY DAY SCHOOL ON
SCHOLARSHIP.
MY YOUNGEST MILES IS TO AND IS
ALREADY A CHATTERBOX LIKE HIS
OLD MAN.
UNFORTUNATELY MY SERVICE IN
COMBAT GET ME NUMEROUS INJURIES
INCLUDING EPILEPTIC TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURIES.
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER.
AND MAJOR DEPRESSIVE DISORDER.
MY SYMPTOMS BECAME WORSE IS MY
ABILITY TO ACCESS MY CLINICIANS
AND TREATMENT THE CLIENT.
I PUSH MY FAMILY AND FRIENDS
AWAY I LOST MY JOB I DROPPED OUT
OF SCHOOL I LOST MY APARTMENT.
I WAS ARRESTED AND HELD IN
PSYCHIATRIC FACILITIES MANY
TIMES.
I WOULD SAY BY SACRAMENTO
VETERANS TREATMENT COURT VA
CLINICIANS AND A SUPPORT NETWORK
OF VETERANS ALL OVER THE CITY
STATE AND COUNTRY.
VETERANS TREATMENT COURT MY VA
PROVIDERS ANOTHER VETERANS
REFUSED TO GIVE UP ON ME.
EVEN WHEN I GIVE UP ON MYSELF.
TODAY HAVE AN APARTMENT THROUGH
HUD BASS WHERE I'VE RECENTLY
BEEN ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE
TENANT ASSOCIATION.
I AM A CONTRIBUTING PROUD AND
LOVING FATHER IN MY SON'S LIFE.
AND I WILL SOON BE STUDYING AT
NORTHWESTERN CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF LAW.
WHAT IS A HOMELESS PERSON LOOK
LIKE?
HOMELESS PERSON LOOKS JUST LIKE
ME.
WHEN YOU MAKE FINANCIAL
INVESTMENTS YOU DON'T SIMPLY
THROW MONEY AT PORTFOLIOS YOU
GET ADVICE FROM SOMEONE WITH
FINANCIAL EXPERIENCE THE KNOWS
WHAT WORKS AND WHAT DOESN'T?
LIKEWISE WHEN YOU INVEST IN THE
HOMELESS COMMUNITY YOU NEED
PEOPLE WITH LIVE HOMELESS
EXPERIENCE TO GET THE GREATEST
RETURNS ON YOUR INVESTMENT IN
THE HOMELESS COMMUNITY.
THAT'S WHY I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
VOTE I'D ON SENATE BILL
[inaudible]
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND ANY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF THIS --
THIS BILL.
HEARING NONE ANY OPPOSITION.
HEARING AND SEEING AND ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE YES
MISS QUIRK SILVA. OH MY GOSH
YOUR TESTIMONY IS JUST SO.
SO IMPACTFUL AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW TOMORROW WE CELEBRATE.
OUR COUNTRY'S BIRTHDAY.
FOR COUNTRY THAT SO MANY OF US
ARE PROUD OF AND AS WE DO THAT.
WE HAVE TO HONOR AND WHEN WE SAY
HONOR THAT WORD HAS TO BE TAKEN
WITH THE SINCERITY IT MEANS
WHICH ARE THOSE WHO A FIGHT FOR
US AND AND IT'S MUCH MORE THAN
THE RED WHITE AND BLUE AND THE
CAKES AND THE PARADES IT'S ABOUT.
INVEST IN THE PEOPLE WHO OF
INVESTED IN US.
AND SO I THINK THE AUTHOR SURE
THIS BILL I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
AND ALSO FOR YOUR BEING WILLING
TO TELL YOUR STORY BECAUSE SO
OFTEN PEOPLE IMAGINE.
WHAT THEY SEE AS HOMELESS AND WE
CREATE THESE IMAGES AND -- AND
IT'S NOT JUST HOMELESS IT'S A
MENTAL HEALTH IT'S WHETHER IT BE
A DRUG USER AND AND THERE'S SUCH
LITTLE TOLERANCE AND SOCIAL
MEDIA HAS MADE THAT EVEN WORSE.
BUT I EAT YOU ARE BRAVE IN YOUR
BOLD IN YOUR HUMBLE AND FOR ME
AND I THINK MANY MANY OTHERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE -- IF THERE'S NO
WATER COMMENTS -- THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWELVE MOTION TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS.
TO HI I GABRIELLE.
GLORIA KILEY.
KILE AYE IMAN.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA -- CENTER VIA FOR
BOTH -- LEAVE THE THE ROLE BUT
FOR OTHER MEMBERS AND ON LATER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME --
UHHUH
.
MORE THAN.
ONE YES OF THE CLERK NOW WOAH --
CALL OF THE YOU'RE MISSING BOTH.
ITEM NUMBER -- THREE SB -- TWO
FIFTY EIGHT EIGHT FIVE TWO ZERO
I ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAMONT I
PLEASE -- FILE IN THE FILING MY
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB
[inaudible]
SEVEN FOUR FOUR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LAMONT.
HOW NON VOTING YES I'M SO SORRY --
AND THEN.
ASSEMBLY -- ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
I'M SO SORRY [inaudible]
CORRECT [inaudible]
I THANK YOU.
AND NOW I AM FILE NUMBER TWELVE
SB.
SIX EIGHT SEVEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEMOND.
A SIMILAR MONTH HI [inaudible]
THANK.
THE THOSE POOR.
IT WAS FULL [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
WIENER
.
I WISH.
SAID
.
WHEN YOU SAY -- ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB TWO FIFTY EIGHT HI.
I ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA AYE --
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE A TWELVE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB.
SIX EIGHT SEVEN HI.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA I ITEM
NUMBER -- THIRTEEN SB.
SEVEN FOUR FOUR HI
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA I N. S. --
THREE FOURTEEN I'M I'M SORRY IS
BE A SEVEN FIFTY FOUR ITEM MY
NUMBER.
FOURTEEN I SUMMER GLORIA AYE
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL
.
THAT'S IT.
YEAH HE I SPOKE [inaudible]
OKAY -- WE ARE NOW BACK TO FILE
ITEM SB FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE SB --
FIVE NINETY TWO CENTER WIENER
YOU MAY BEGIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- BUT FIRST I WANT TO
THANK.
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE --
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS.
IN ADDITION -- I DID WORK OUT
SOME ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE -- WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL WHO I
KNOW HAD TO LEAVE FOR A FAMILY
OBLIGATION -- BUT I WANT TO JUST --
NOTE THAT WE WORK OUT SOME
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE THAT WAS
SUBMITTED -- TO MAKE -- CRYSTAL
CLEAR -- WHAT IS WE KNOW ABOUT
THAT HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
OPERA BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN SOME?
MISINFORMATION AND THE COMMUNITY
JUST TO MAKE CRYSTAL CLEAR --
THIS BILL DOES NOT IN ANY WAY
CHANGE LOCAL ZONING -- HEIGHTS
OR SET BACKS OR DESIGN STANDARDS --
DE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY OCT
FUNDAMENTALLY.
IS ABOUT REQUIRING COMMUNITIES
TO COMPLY WITH THEIR OWN RULES
THAT WHEN THEY ADOPT RULES
AROUND ZONING -- HEIZER NUMBER
OF UNITS OR WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE -- THAT THEY NEED TO
COMPLY WITH THEIR OWN.
RULES.
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY TWO
CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW IN THE
THIRTY SEVEN YEAR OLD HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT -- THIS IS
NOT A NEW LAW THIS IS A THIRTY
SEVEN YEAR OLD LAW THAT I WAS
WITH PASS WHEN I WAS TWELVE
YEARS OLD -- AND THIS CLARIFIES
SEVERAL ASPECTS AND STRENGTHENS
SEVERAL EXISTING PROVISIONS TO
ENSURE THE NEW HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IS PROTECTED AGAINST.
PRIVILEGED TO PERMIT THIS
APPROVALS FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
ARE THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT -- WAS -- STRENGTHENED A FEW
YEARS AGO AS WELL AND IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR SAID
HOUSING LAW HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IT SERVES AS A PRIMARY
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM -- TO
PROTECT AGAINST INAPPROPRIATE
PROJECT IS APPROVALS WINDOWS
DISAPPROVAL WHEN AS PROJECTS
COMPLY WITH LOCAL STANDARDS.
I'M THE ACT HAS SEVERAL
AMBIGUITIES THAT HAVE ARISEN --
BECOME A PARENT A RECENT YEARS --
AND THIS BILL WILL CLARIFY THOSE
AMBIGUITIES -- OF SICK OF NOTE
THE BILL CLARIFIES THE
DEFINITIONS OF QUOTE UNQUOTE
LOWER DENSITY AND QUORUM COURT
REDUCTION IN DENSITY -- TO MAKE
CLEAR OF THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT APPLIES TO
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS -- AND
ALSO -- TO ADDING BEDROOMS AND
EXISTING HOMES -- CLARIFIES THAT
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
ALSO APPLIES TO MINISTERIAL
HOUSING APPROVALS -- AND EVELYN
ENHANCE THE ENFORCEMENT AND
JUDICIAL REMEDIES OFFER BAD
FAITH -- DISAPPROVAL OF PROJECTS
WERE WAS CLEAR THAT IT WAS
ILLEGAL TO APPROVE THE PROJECT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND WITH ME TODAY ARE THOSE
BRONTE FROM CALIFORNIA UMB.
PEDRO GO FROM THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND JENNIFER STRUCK
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS.
RIGHT SURE MEMBERS I LUIS
MARATHI WITH CALIFORNIAN BE --
WOULD ECHO -- THE THE SENATORS
VERY APT RUN DOWN OF SB FIVE
NINE TWO WERE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT CLICK IT MAKES
IMPORTANT CLARIFICATIONS -- TO
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
ON ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS
WHICH THIS COMMITTEE HAS
DISCUSSED DISCUSSED QUITE A BIT --
THIS YEAR THERE'S SOME AMBIGUITY
ABOUT WHETHER THE HA APPLIES --
TO EIGHTY IS AND THIS BILL WOULD
CLARIFY THAT AMBIGUITY STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE OF GOOD FOR THE YEAH
COULD MORNING MISTER VICE CHAIR --
MY NAME IS PATRICK OFF ON WITH
THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF SB.
FIVE NINE TWO AND PRIMARILY
BECAUSE SB FIVE NINE TWO WE
BELIEVE WILL CONTINUE TO HELP
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT IT CLOSES LOOPHOLES IN
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
THAT -- DO NOT SPECIFY WHETHER
MINISTERIO APPROVALS ARE COVERED
OR NOT AND DESK PROVIDES THAT
CRITICAL CLARITY.
MOST OF THE MOST OF THE
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL TO HAVE
BEEN ISSUED IN CALIFORNIA UNDER
SB THIRTY FIVE HAVE BEEN 4100%
AFFORDABLE DEVELOPMENTS -- AND
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT THOSE THAT
THOSE DEVELOPMENTS GAP BUILD
WITHOUT DELAY -- AND SO -- AND
AND PEACH HAS ALSO HISTORICALLY
BEING SUPPORTIVE OF ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS AND WE CONTINUE
TO WE BELIEVE THAT THE LAW
SHOULD BE EXTENDED TO PROTECT
THOSE UNITS AS WELL.
AND SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER SECOND
HALF CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE ARE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL -- SPECIFICALLY I JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT -- THE GOAL OF THE
BILL IS TO HELP HOMEOWNERS TO BE
ABLE TO BUILD EIGHTY USING THEIR
TONIGHT BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
EVEN IF THEY'RE CONCERT
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE CONSISTENT
WITH PLANNING AND ZONING IN
DESIGN.
THE GOAL IS TO GIVE A PROPERTY
OWNERS THE ABILITY MADE HOLE AT
THE END OF THE DAY IF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DOES THE WRONG THING
WE'RE HOPING THE HOMEOWNERS
WON'T HAVE TO USE THE HA IN
ORDER TO DEVELOP THE REACHED A
THEIR TO USE.
BUT THIS WILL HOPEFULLY MOVE US
FARTHER DOWN THE ROAD FOR
COMPLETING THE THE EIGHTY YOU
GOALS OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
HIS NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHAEL GUNNING
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
SILVIO PRIME YOU HAVE A FACEBOOK
IN SUPPORT.
CAME TO ME ON BEHALF OF TECHNO
DEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
TODD DAVID AND THEY HAVE THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE SHIRKY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
HI FOR ME ON BEHALF AS VIçT
HOME AND SAN HELP PROPERTIES IN
SUPPORT.
ANOTHER WITH THE WESTERN TERM ON
POVERTY WE HAVE A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL --
APPRECIATE AUTHORS WILLINGNESS
TO WORK WITH US ON OUR LANGUAGE
IN PARTICULAR APPRECIATE THE
REMOVAL OF THE ECONOMIC
VIABILITY LANGUAGE AND SINGLE
FAMILY HOME LANGUAGE -- WHEN
FILLS IN PRINT I'M HOPEFUL THAT
WE'LL BE ABLE TO GET INTO A
SUPPORT POSITION?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
HEARING [inaudible]
TO ALL [inaudible] TWELVE
FIFTEEN GOOD MORNING ME TO JUST
PLAY A LITTLE BIT MY NAME'S ERIC
PHILLIPS AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION -- WE WOULD VERY
MUCH LIKE TO THANK THEM THE
AUTHOR AND COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING VERY HARD ON THIS BILL
TO ADDRESS.
MOST OF OUR CONCERNS AM I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THAT ALTHOUGH WE
CONTINUE TO BE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED TO THIS BILL -- WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE EFFORT IN
THE MOVEMENT WE'VE SEEN THERE
ARE JUST A FEW.
KEY ISSUES THAT WE THINK WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO BE ADDRESSED
BEFORE WE CAN REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
AND THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT IS INTENDED TO YOU -- LIMIT
THE DISCRETION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO YOU TONIGHT OR
REDUCE THE DENSITY OF PROJECTS
THAT DISCRETION DOES NOT COME
INTO PLAY FOR MINISTERIAL
APPROVAL SO THE INCORPORATION.
OF MINISTERIAL PERMITS
THROUGHOUT THE H. A. -- CREATES
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES AND
POTENTIAL CONFLICTS WITH THE
CODE OF CIVIL PROCEDURE AND WE
THINK THAT THERE IS A WAY TO YOU.
M. INCREASE THE ACCOUNTABILITY
ASPECT IN BY INCORPORATING
REMEDIES UNDER TEN EIGHTY FIVE
ACTIONS FOR MINISTERIAL PERMIT
ENFORCEMENT -- THROUGH THE HA A
AND WE HOPE TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSING THAT WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE BECAUSE WE THINK -- THAT
THAT CAN.
HELP ADDRESS THIS THIS REAL
CONCERN ON THE OTHER SUBSTANTIVE
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
BILL IS THE IDEA OF COMPENSATORY
DAMAGES BEING ENFORCED AGAINST --
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT.
VIOLATE THE HA A THE HJ ALREADY
HAS A VERY STEEP FINANCIAL
PENALTIES INCORPORATED AND IT.
AND M. THE ADDITION OF
COMPENSATORY DAMAGES AGAINST A
POTENTIAL THAT.
EITHER DEVELOPERS POTENTIAL
FUTURE RESIDENTS COULD EXPOSE
I'M LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ALMOST
UNLIMITED -- UNLIMITED LIABILITY
AND AND THAT IS A SERIOUS
CONCERN AND AND SOMETHING THAT
WE CONTINUE TO BE OPPOSED TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
PLEASE OF HI I'M PETER
PAPADOPOULOS AND I'M WITH THE
MISSION ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AND THE MISSION DISTRICT
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND WE ARE A MUNITY BASED
COMMUNITY SERVING ORGANIZATION
WE SURVIVE ROUGHLY SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED MOSTLY LOW INCOME LATINO
FAMILIES A YEAR.
IN THE AREAS OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ASSET BUILDING AND WE ARE ALSO
AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER --
WE APPRECIATE THAT STEPS SEEM TO
BE TAKEN TODAY TO MAKE SOME
AMENDMENTS TO SOME OF THE AREAS.
THAT WE HAD CONCERNS ABOUT AND I
THINK THAT I WILL NEED TO STUDY
THAT THIS IS OF COURSE A NEW
BILL TO US AS A AS IT MOVED INTO
ANOTHER BILL.
AND WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT WHAT
THESE NEW AMENDMENTS ARE THEY
SEEM TO MAKE AT LEAST ONE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE THAT.
CLARIFIED SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT DISCRETION WE STILL DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
DISCRETION IN THIS BILL AND HOW
IT INTERSECTS WITH MINISTERIAL
ISSUES AGAIN -- WERE UNCLEAR
ABOUT DID -- IN WHAT WAYS MIGHT
IT TAKE AWAY.
AREAS OF MINISTERIAL APPROVALS
WHERE THERE IS IN FACT CURRENTLY
A MECHANISM FOR A COMMUNITY
MEMBER WITHIN OF ALL THEIR BOOK
COMMUNITY. TO HAVE AN A COURSE
OF ACTION.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE MAINTAINING.
THEIR CULTURAL ECOSYSTEM WITHIN
A SO.
THE MAIN THING THAT WE WE WOULD
STRESS AS WE'D LIKE TO SEE THESE
CHANGES CONTINUE WE STUFF OTHER
POTENTIAL CONCERNS BECAUSE WILL
REALLY WANTING TO MOVE THIS THAT
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
AND ALL OF THE STATE HOUSING
BILLS FROM WHERE THEY ARE NOW
WHICH IS A SORT OF START AS A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
MARKET SOLUTIONS BASED APPROACH
AND THEN WE CHASE WITH
MITIGATION ELEMENTS AND WE'D
REALLY LIKE TO SEE.
A SHIFT TO A PROGRAM WHERE WE'RE
STARTING WITH AN OVERALL EQUITY
BASED FRAMEWORK RIGHT SO WE'RE
STARTING BY SAYING WE KNOW WE
NEED DEVELOPMENT WE NEED
EQUITABLE DEVELOPMENT AS WE
BUILD OUT OUR STAY AS WE BUILD
THE HOUSING WE NEED DURING THIS
CRISIS.
HOW DO WE START WITH A FILTER
THAT SAYS?
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE
THOUGHT OF AND THAT THEY'RE IN A
ABLE TO TO THRIVE AND TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES AS A STARTING POINT
RIGHT THERE.
WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED THAT IT
COULD PUT SOME -- COST ON TO
NEIGHBORHOODS -- WITH SOME
ELEMENTS AGAIN BOTH THROUGH THE
LITIGATION ASPECTS OF THIS BILL
AS WELL AS DOES THE MINISTERIAL
IN OTHER KINDA SHIFTS.
ARE ALL ELEMENTS OF DISCRETION
OFF THE TABLE WE WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE SURE THEY ARE BECAUSE AGAIN
THAT WILL MOVE COSTS ON TO
ALREADY OVERBURDENED VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU AND THEN JUST ONE MORE --
TESTIMONY SURE -- MISTER VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE APPRECIATE
THE THE SENATOR TAKEN THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS IT
CERTAINLY PROVIDES THE NEED A
CLARITY THAT WE WERE LOOKING FOR
IT NARROWS THE BILL A FAIR
AMOUNT.
AND WE DO AGREE WITH THE CENTER
OF THE HOUSE KIND OF ELECTRIC
POWERFUL OFTEN FOR YOU KNOW
SINCE -- NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO IT
WAS MADE EVEN MORE POWERFUL WITH
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT
FINDS -- IF WE DENY A PROJECT
UNLAWFULLY AND THAT'S WHY WE
FEEL AS THOUGH WE DO NOT NEED TO
BRING A CHEMISTRY DAMAGES --
INTO THE EQUATION WE THINK THAT
GOES A BIT TOO FAR I'M
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE HAVEN'T
SEEN REALLY ANY VIOLATIONS HOUSE
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT SINCE THIS
LEGISLATURE STRENGTH IMAGES BUT
A YEAR AND A HALF AGO -- BUT WE
WOULD COULD CONTAIN A WORK AT
THE CENTER AND HOPE WE CAN GET
THE COMPENSATORY DAMAGES TINKER
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THEN NOW WITH THAT --
STREET THREE IF -- IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE WHO PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RAN MARTIN
ON THE HAVE THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IT'S HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION WE HAVE BEEN
OPPOSE THE BILL WE APPRECIATE
THE SENATOR TAKEN THE AMENDMENTS
THAT HE DID.
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THEM IN
PRINT AND HOPEFULLY TO REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION AT THAT POINT
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
ALEX GIVES HERE WE HAVE THE
CITIES OF LAFAYETTE IN CUPERTINO
WE'D LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
FROM THE LEAGUE AND IN
OPPOSITION.
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA.
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT
TAKEN TODAY A LINE MY COMMENTS
WITH A PH THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CARA ROUGHLY HALF
THE CITY OF SAN MARCOS
APPRECIATE THEIR MOMENTS AGAIN
AND WE LINE OUR COMMENTS WOULD
LEAD TO CITIES.
THANK YOU ANY -- ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
I HAVE A STATEMENT -- BUT I NEED
TO READ FROM THE MARCH SHERMAN
OF DAVID CHIU -- EVEN GOVERNMENT
FINANCES.
OF DAVID SAYS THE THANK YOU FOR
AGREEING TO THE AMENDMENT TO I
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THE
AUTHOR AGREED TO DELETE TO
PROVISIONS.
OF WE AGREED TO WORK ON THEM IN
THE SUMMER RECESS TO SEE IF THEY
COULD BE ADDED BACK IN -- AND
THOSE INCLUDE -- THE INCLUSION
OF SINGLE UNIT IN THE H. A A AND
WHETHER A COURT SHOULD LOOK AT
WHAT OUR CITY REDUCE THE
ECONOMIC VIABILITY.
AS A CONDITION THAT LIMITS A
HOUSING PROJECT ABILITY TO
PROVIDE HOUSING -- IF THERE IS
AN AGREEMENT WAS STAKEHOLDERS WE
CAN REVISIT THESE ISSUES WITH
POTENTIAL AMENDS BEFORE THE
SESSION IS OVER -- FROM OUR
CHAIRMAN AND WITH THAT -- THE
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE AMENDMENT WILL BE TAKEN IN
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
SO THEY CAN BE HERE IN THE HERE
SO THEY CAN HEAR THE BILL ON
JULY.
YES AND I MAY COVER THE THE
LANGUAGE I INDICATED THAT THE
CAR THAT -- WE WORKED OUT WITH
THE SUMMER GABRIEL -- HE WAS TOO
LATE TO GET INTO WHAT WILL NEED
TO COST TODAY SO WE'LL TAKE THAT
AMENDMENT AND NEXT WEEK AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT [inaudible]
OKAY OF SIR WE DO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE EXPECT WEST RIVAL.
THANK YOU.
MOTION TO FAST TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CHIU.
DEEP HI I GABRIELLE GLORIA
GLORIA I KILEY KILEY I IN THE
MONTH. TO MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN
QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA AYE
[inaudible]
CITY -- WE THE THE BILL IS OUT
WILL WILL HOLD THE THE ROLL CALL
OPEN FOR A MODEST AT ON CUE.
CALL ME TO SHARE [inaudible]
WITH
.
WE'RE RECONVENING THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING COMMITTEE MY APOLOGIES I
WAS UNFORTUNATELY PRESENTING.
A BILL I HAD ANOTHER COMMITTEE
BUT I'M BACK AND I WILL ADD ON
TO OTHER VOTES MADAM SECRETARY.
I AM NUMBER.
THREE ITEM NUMBER THREE TWO
FIFTY EIGHT HI I I NUMBER ITEM
NUMBER.
NINE OF FIVE NINETY TWO WASHU I
NUMBER TWO AND NUMBER TWELVE SB
SIX EIGHT SEVEN SURE.
I A NUMBER -- FOURTEEN SB SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR CHIU AYE AYE.
OKAY.
AT THIS TIME THE MEETING IS NOW
ADJOURNED